dangerous or damaging or deadly that you
are bringing it down as quickly as
possible
yes we are investing in more Spanish
language content moderation and yes we
will once we identify okay valuative
content we'll take it down as soon as
possible thank you and your testimony
today isn't the only opportunity for you
to commit to answering questions to this
committee so I'd like you to forward to
this committee again I'm not asking for
Trade Secrets but I would like to get
some semblance of understanding as to
how much you are investing with the
number of bodies the number of people
the number of resources in making sure
that you are investing more in pulling
down content that is either deadly or
dangerous on your platform can you
forward that to the committee and I wish
I could my team get back to you on this
thank you very much appreciate that
opportunity
um as was mentioned earlier uh it might
sound a little funny but you have in
fact been one of the few people to unite
this committee uh members Republicans
and Democrats to be in agreement that we
are frustrated with Tick Tock we're
upset with talk and yes you keep
mentioning that there are industry
issues that not only Tick Tock faces but
others you remind me a lot of Mike
Zuckerberg uh he when he came here I
said to my staff he reminds you Fred
Astaire good dancer with words and you
are doing the same today a lot of your
answers are a bit nebulous they're not
yes or no so I'd like to ask you a
question
yes or no
is your Revenue going up at Tick Tock
month over month or year over year
yes our revenue is going up okay over
here and with that
some of the answers I'd like you to
forward this committee is are you
investing more and more money into
making sure that content that is
dangerous and or deadly you're investing
more and more resources in that aspect
of your expenditures and your commitment
to your users and to your your
organization
yes I commit to that and we will we are
investing more and we will continue to
do that okay my last question is this
um are you a Chinese company
Tick Tock is a company that's now
headquartered in Singapore and Los
Angeles okay we are not available in
mainland China I would use this uh in
other countries around the world okay is
there a corporation that has any
Authority above tick tock
Tick Tock is a subsidiary of bike dance
which is founded by a Chinese founder
ahas and bike dance is a Chinese company
well bike dance owns many businesses
that operates in China is it or is it
not a Chinese company uh Congressman the
way we look at it it was founded by
Chinese so I'm not asking how you look
at it fact is it a Chinese company or
not for example Dell is a company it's
an American company they have activities
all over the world is
a Chinese company I frequently have this
discussions with others on what is a
company that is now global that that's
okay I prefer you answer the question
and stop dancing verbally on it Madam
chair my time is expired thank you very
much gentlemen yields back chair
recognizes the gentleman from California
Mr obanolti well thank you very much Mr
Chu it's nice to see you again
uh if I could just bring us back up to
30 000 feet for a second I just want to
talk about what we're afraid of here you
know what what we fear might happen uh
social media companies and tick knock is
unique in this is not unique in this
gather a tremendous amount of user data
and then use powerful AI tools to use
that data to make eerily accurate
predictions of human behavior and then
seek to manipulate that behavior that's
something that it's not just Tick Tock
it's all our social media companies that
are doing this ultimately the solution
is to enact comprehensive Federal data
privacy legislation that will prevent
that kind of behavior or at least allow
users to consent to it and that's I know
something that the chair is working on
the ranking member I hope that this
committee will act on that this year the
specific concern here though
as regards Tick Tock is that this type
of capability falling into the hands of
foreign countries uh is something that
has National Security implications and
that's why Congress is getting involved
on this issue so I know that you have
proposed project Texas in an effort to
alleviate these fears so I wanted to ask
some specific technical questions about
project Texas and the way that you
believe that it will solve this problem
so one of the things that you've said in
your testimony is that part of project
Texas will have engineers at Oracle
going through the source code for tick
tock uh how large is that code base
um well it's not small but it's not just
Oracle Congressman we are also inviting
other third-party monitors we're in the
process of figuring out who the best
um
we're talking Millions tens of millions
of lines of code how big is the base it
is significant um but it's something
that we believe can be done and again I
want to say that I don't I have not
heard of another another company
American or not allowed for this to
happen but I mean you're kind of at a
new unique position having to to answer
these concerns of Congress so are they
going through the code for just the app
or the app and the server code
I can get back to you on the technical
details but it's it's comprehensive
including the software that powers the a
lot of the software that powers the
experience and how long will that review
take
I need to get back to you on the
timeline but we are progressing quite
well on Project Texas and whenever we
hit the Milestone I commit to be very
transparent about it okay
so I'm wondering
because I'm also concerned uh as a
software engineer about the process in
which new code is introduced into the
code base do you use a software
configuration management system at Tick
Tock the way we plan for a new code to
be done is that even before the code
becomes live it has to be reviewed the
changes have to be reviewed about a code
review that was that was good that was
another question I had for you so the
code review is it done with a team of
Engineers or just with a single engineer
or it's going to be a team okay yeah and
that's that's going to be done at Oracle
or elsewhere uh is if it's going to be
done in one of our transfer transparency
centers so that we you know we still
need to make sure that the code itself
is secure and okay so yeah what I'm
hearing you say is that even though the
code might be written by someone not in
the United States before the code is
integrated it'll be reviewed in a code
review by a team of Engineers within the
United States that's the plan okay and
this back to the question about the
software configuration management system
how do you how do you manage the
integration of that code change into the
rest of the tick tock code base the long
and short of it is we have built a team
of American personnel with security
credentials the person who leads the
team used to work for the Secret Service
I mean there's there's a software
solution for integrating those code
changes into the code base what's what
solution is that
I would need to charge someone get back
to you on the details well specifically
what I'd like to know is to make sure
that this isn't something that Tick Tock
has has created Uh custom which many
companies do because that would mean
that you'd have to review the code
source code for that as well for
security uh how do you protect against
threats like uh the a malicious actor
being hired not by Tick Tock but by uh
by Oracle for example or by uh by usds
the um the approach that most companies
take for these things is to have several
layers of monitoring to make sure that
everything everything that somebody has
reviewed there's a secondary review so
that one malicious actor is not able to
create the damage then the malicious
sector can do but you rightly pointed
out these kind of problems are
industry-wide problems right every
company has to do with them okay well
let me ask a specific question about
that I mean I I uh
in thinking about if I if I were a
malicious actor a software engineer on
one of your projects how I would go
about writing a malicious code I
wouldn't put it right there and say hey
I'm malicious I would put unrelated
lines of code in different sections of
the code that work together to do
something malicious how do you think
that that could get caught uh again you
know we have to rely on third-party
experts to help us with that I think
there are enough experts who can catch a
lot of these things the work on security
globally on all data security is never
perfect yeah but we can we can have a
lot of oversight to keep it safer than
any other experience I I appreciate uh
the effort my concern Mr Chu is I don't
believe that it is technically possible
to accomplish what Tick Tock says it
will accomplish through project Texas I
just think that there are two too many
uh back doors through that process to
allow that to be possible and I think a
malicious actor would succeed in
inserting malicious code in there if
they wanted to I but I hope we I see
we're out of time I hope we get an
opportunity to talk some more about this
I yield back manager gentleman yields
back chair recognizes the gentlelady
from Michigan Mrs Dingle thank you
chairman Rogers and ranking member
pallone for holding this hearing and to
Mr Chu for testifying here today your
good news you're halfway through with me
as screen time increases so do inherent
risks and with the proliferation and
popularity of new social media platforms
so does the potential reach of dangerous
provocative and often harmful content
and my fear the abuse of collected data
as a representative from the state of
Michigan I can speak from experience on
how social media has been used to Target
members of the Michigan delegation
including a palate to kidnap our
governor and how it can be weaponized to
perpetuate harms towards individuals and
communities and you saw firsthand how it
targeted the chair of this committee
today many of my college colleagues on
both sides of the aisle have raised
legitimate concerns about protecting
Children online
misinformation and securing our data
concerns that I share and has been said
by many of my colleagues are
bipartisanly shared
I think of many ways these Myriad of
issues highlight the need for
comprehensive data privacy legislation
that would ensure the safety and
integrity of every American's data on
every social media platform and mitigate
potential Harms
one important area of concern I have
regarding data collection is geolocation
data and how it can be abused I've seen
it abused I have seen women die because
it has been abused
this subject has dangerous implications
for survivors of domestic violence
people seeking Medical Care and
protecting children from potential
predators
Mr true in your testimony you wrote that
current versions of the app do not
collect precise or approximate GPS
information from U.S users yes or no
answers please
Mr Chu have any prior versions of tick
tock's app collected precise GPS
information from U.S users yes or no yes
from back in 2020 about three years ago
are there currently tic-tock users who
still hold old versions of the app that
collect precise GPS information from us
users yes or no that could be but that's
a small percentage still dangerous has
Tick Tock at any time fed precise GPS
information collected from U.S users
into algorithms to serve user ads yes or
no
I will need to check on the details
because we do not currently collect that
so I need to check on the details yeah
I'm sure there's a yes there but has
Tick Tock at any time fed precise GPS
information collected from U.S users
into logarithms so no I'm happy talk
today to make inferences about users yes
or no
I'm not sure if they're specific so I'd
like answers yes or no after this has
Tick Tock at any time sold precise GPS
information collected from us users yes
or no
we do not sell data to data Brokers if
that's the question that and you've
never done that
I do not believe so
as Tick Tock at any time sold or share
parties
inferences that were made using in part
or in whole precise GPS information
collected from us users yes or no
Congressman I need to check on these
specifics what I can tell you is right
now we do not collect precise GPS
location data in the United States all
right does Tic Tac still use inferences
that were made using in part or in whole
precise GPS information collected from
U.S users
I'm sorry would you repeat that
does tick tock still use info
were made using heart inner
inner size GP
from us users in your algorithm that
will be a very technical question I will
have to check and get back to you has
Tick Tock at any time provided the
Chinese government with either precise
GSP information collected from U.S users
or inferences made from that data that I
can give you a straighter no
Mr Chu even in Congress even if Congress
were to ban Tick-Tock I'm concerned that
China or others would still have access
to U.S consumer data by purchasing
purchasing it through data Brokers will
you commit not to sell any optic tax
data to data data Brokers now or in the
future
we do not do that we do not sell data
the data broke us now will you commit to
not do it in the future
this is a certain members of the
industry who do this you know I think
this has to be broad legislation to help
us the whole industry address this
problem
I think I'm out of time
Madam chair I'll yield back generally
yields back
chair yields five minutes to the
gentleman from Alabama Mr Palmer thank
you when
the Chinese communist government bought
a sheer bite dance it's been described
as as the Chinese Communist government's
way of choir form of control and that
companies have a little choice in
selling a stake to the government
if they want to stay in business and
what I'd like to know is when the
Chinese communist government moved to
buy shares of bite dance were you
informed beforehand yes or no
no Congressman bite dance were you or
anyone will Tick-Tock ask for your
opinion about the sale of shares of bike
dance
to the Chinese communist government yes
or no it just it hasn't happened uh did
you or anyone employed by or affiliated
with Tick Tock State any objections or
concerns about the possibility the
Chinese communist government once they
had chairs and bite dance exercising
control over content using your platform
for conducting misinformation campaigns
or restrictions ensuring nothing is
posted reflects badly on the Chinese
communist government or for surveillance
and data collection for use against
anyone
did any of your you or anyone affiliated
with Tick Tock raise any concerns about
that
Congressman we do not collect we do not
I didn't ask you that we do not promote
did you raise any concerns about it
because that's why we're here but we do
not promote or remove it behalf of the
Chinese government
communicate in any form or fashion with
the directors of bite dance that there
might be concerns about government
control over content did yes or no did
you either did or you didn't Congressman
you did I just wanted to make this clear
we do not remove or promote content at
the request of the Chinese talk insiders
have already said the company is tightly
controlled by bite dance it even gets
down to the hours they work
so obviously you didn't say anything
there's a serious concern by Chinese
companies privately held companies about
doing anything against what the Chinese
communist government wants I want to ask
you this does tick tock screen against
manipulative content from Child
Predators yes or no do we screen do you
screen against them uh yeah we do this
about drug cartels drug cartels
cartel that was engaged in a police
chase with Spanish authorities and they
posted it on Tick Tock and got over a
million views why wasn't that taken down
and are you doing it with human
traffickers or terrorists I mean
do you
withhold content
um from Nations that might be committing
crimes against humanity
yes or no Congressman our platform is
yes it's a freedom of expression and
uses to talk about that but yes or no do
you screen against content
from Nations that commit crimes against
humanity the congressman I will use this
comments yes sir no yes or no you need
points of views they don't want and it's
a commitment to keep this let me ask you
this Michael beckerlin who is your vice
president and head of public policy for
America is right
um
is he part of the team that helped you
prepare for this meeting yes or no
um can I clarify who you mean Michael
Beckerman yes he is okay where is he at
this moment
I'm sorry where's Mr Beckerman at this
moment
he's probably here no you know he's here
he's sitting right behind you I want to
know why
when Mr Beckerman was on with Jake
Tapper on CNN
and asked repeatedly
to condemn uh Chinese true Chinese
Communist government's treatment of the
uyghurs
when that treatment has been classified
by the United States as a genocide one a
U.N report classified as it as a crime
against humanity why after multiple
questions Mr Beckerman refused to
address that
are you afraid of the Chinese communist
government
no because you can find their content on
our platform any content that our users
head of public policy for the Americas
and and an American on an American
television news channel
why couldn't he say why couldn't he
condemn that I think it's very important
to look at our platform and if you use
out and open our apps
asking about your personnel now because
Personnel is policy everybody in this
room understands that except maybe you
Personnel is probably let me let me just
conclude with this
and I hate to bring this up because I
this is part of the stuff that I've said
but deceptionist fundamental the Chinese
Communist party's political intelligence
and Military strategy and you have
repeatedly used the word transparency
throughout this hearing and every time
you've said it what I've heard is
deception I yield back
gentleman yields back chair recognizes
gentleman from Texas Mr VC for five
minutes uh thank you madam chair
um I got to tell you Mr Chu
um as a father of a 16 year old that
likes social media uh the a lot of your
evasiveness today in answering many of
these questions really disturbs me
because I can tell you that uh the
teenagers of today they really don't
want to be on Facebook they they won't
they want your platform
and you were asked to come before this
committee uh to testify about many
things and and a lot of us are worried
about our kids personal data
um as the co-chair of the Congressional
voting rights caucus also worried that
Tick Tock is the world's most powerful
and extensive propaganda machine
allowing the Chinese Communist party to
use tick tock's platform to influence
public opinion and undermine the
Integrity of our Democratic elections
and I have a report
uh called Tick Tock and Facebook failed
to detect election disinformation in the
U.S while YouTube succeeds and this
report was published by the non-profit
Global witness and the cyber security
for democracy team at NYU and the
purpose of the study was to test
platforms like Tick Tock and whether or
not they can detect and take down false
political ads targeted at U.S voters
young voters ahead of last year's
midterm elections and according to this
report 90 percent of election
disinformation ads tested were approved
by your platform
again that is ninety percent of ads
containing false and misleading election
misinformation uh went undetected on
Tick Tock and just to add some color to
the type of misleading ads that were
approved by Tick Tock this included ads
that were live on Tick Tock that said
the wrong election day and actually
encouraged people to vote twice you do
know that voting twice as a felony
Mr Chu you didn't know that it's legal
to vote twice Congressman any
misinformation that comes around a
political reaction is something we take
very seriously let me um I'm
particularly terrible about this type of
information
uh because it can run rampant on Tick
Tock and given that Tick Tock again uh
y'all are appealing to a very young and
diverse user base that is exactly uh the
people that we've seen targeted time and
time again with uh voter suppression
campaigns run by malicious actors Mr
Chew do you agree with me that is that
it is completely unacceptable that 90 of
these ads were undetected on your
platform and can you detail for us right
now tick tock's policy regarding
election misinformation and paid
political ads and how the company
monitors such information and how you
plan to get that number down to zero
while stick talk is a place for our
users to come and express their points
of views freely we do take
misinformation dangerous information
particularly around an election very
seriously I will work with third-party
experts to identify Miss um
misinformation and you call allowing 90
of false content political content on
your platform to be taken called you
call that you define that as being taken
seriously I I um I need to look into the
specifics I I'm you know not sure where
the number came from but I can tell you
Congressman that we are the only
platform that I know of that doesn't
actually take political ads I don't we
don't accept money I don't think other
platforms can say that Mr Sue can you
detail how you responded to that report
did you respond to that report that I
just mentioned
I I need to look at the specifics of the
report congressman and I can get back to
you on that all right Mr Chu I want to
shift to project Texas I know that we've
discussed this initiative throughout
today's hearing but I want to dive
deeper into your notion that promises
about project Texas should give us any
confidence and tick tock's ability to
localize U.S data and discontinue access
to that data uh to bite dance employees
in China uh why because we've already
had a tick tock executive appear before
Congress and give sworn testimony about
the comfort that we should take in tick
tock's us-based resources
well Tick Tock uh data security
practices were being scrutinized by the
US government and unfortunately uh We've
since found out uh from a uh from
journalism recorded conversations uh
that those assurances were uh were
worthless uh in your testimony you also
mentioned that Oracle has already begun
inspecting Tick Tock source code and has
access to the platform's recommendation
algorithm uh why should this give the
American public any great assurances
particularly uh given that Oracle now
owns a stake in Tick Tock and sends the
gain monetarily the more Revenue The
Tick Tock and its algorithm generates
Congressman not only is Project tactus
unprecedented in our industry in
protecting U.S user data and interests
we are inviting third parties to come in
and monitor this and we will you know be
transparent in that process and this is
more Beyond most all companies that I
know of my industry thank you madam
chair I'm out of time
back share recognizes
in Florida for five minutes Mr
thank you very much Madam chair Mr Chu
I'm aware that on arriving in uh DC this
week you appeared on Tick Tock about
said you had 150 million U.S users 5
million U.S businesses that represents a
lot of data
you also referenced your appearance
before this committee as a chance to
share all the tick tock is doing to
protect Americans using the app
Mr Chu has bite dance spied on Americans
at the direction of the Chinese
Communist Party
no
uh Madam chair I'd like to enter into
the record uh this October 20th 22
Forbes article entitled Tick Tock parent
bite dance plan to use tick tock to
monitor the physical location of
specific U.S citizens without objections
thank you
the project assigned that this to a
Beijing leaded team and they were going
to follow individual American citizens I
ask you again Mr Chu has fight dance
spied on American citizens I don't think
that spying is the right way to describe
it this is ultimately we can differ
or bite dance data that is viewed stored
or passes through China is subject to
the laws of China One party
authoritarian State hostile to All
American Standards of privacy China's
court system reports to and falls under
the Chinese Communist Party
and like fentanyl analogs which we all
know are also manufactured in China
although they are illegal there I fear
Tic Tac will Tick-Tock will grow into a
much bigger problem a cancer if you will
I'm deeply worried that it may be too
late to stop the spread of this cancer
like fentanyl another China export which
causes addiction and death
dangerous algorithms and Chinese
Communist Party are not good for
Americans not good for our families and
definitely not good for the United
States
Mr Chu prior to serving as the CFO of
bike dance you served as a CFO and
director Global operations for show me
from 2015 to 21 is that correct
are you asking me in 2015 very good
would you mind painting that face Madam
chair I'd like to uh enter another
article into evidence uh uh this is from
uh the national cyber security Center in
Lithuania without objections ordered
thank you this report outlines numerous
data security risk including how the
privacy of European users was violated
in clear cases of unauthorized
collection of user data by show me this
sells exactly what many of my colleagues
have been talking about today where she
had to show me these phones sold to
Europeans had a list of 449 words and
phrases which would be automatically
censored on the device
censored phrases included The Voice of
America and Democratic movement among
others this analysis was conducted on
devices which are manufactured and sold
to Europeans while you were the head of
operations for show me
it does not follow that you expect us to
believe that you would not censor on
behalf of the Chinese Communist Party
since you've already done so I want to
be unequivocal on this we do not remove
all promote content
your word strives to deliver on your
mission to inspire creativity and bring
joy to American users I assure you that
is not the mission or goal of the
Chinese Communist party which runs the
People's Republic of China that
tick-tocks parent company bike dances
domiciled in Mr Congressman you can
check with our users
you have not given straightforward
answers we don't find you credible on
these things uh and uh with that Madam
chair I'd like to yield the balance
Congressman you have given me no time to
answer your questions I reject the
characterizations
well thank you madam chair uh Mr Chu I'd
like to continue our discussion at
project Texas if we could part of
project Texas is that engineers at
Oracle will review the algorithms used
by Tick Tock to confirm that they're
free of foreign influence
uh I have a question about that because
we're talking about uh AI That's a very
generic term do you use machine learning
to influence the algorithms at tick tock
in uh this gets very technical and we
have published several blogs about this
which I can forward to your team okay
um but yes it's mainly based on interest
signals right okay so yeah so here's my
question how could looking at the
algorithm
confirm that it's for free from foreign
influence because the algorithm is just
a neural net architecture with inputs
and outputs and weights and how to train
that I mean the influence is an external
Factor so I'd appreciate it if you could
if you could give us I see we're out of
time again a written answer to that but
again I'm concerned that what you're
proposing with project Texas just
doesn't have the technical capability of
providing us the assurances that we need
I go back Madam chair
gentleman yields back chair recognizes
Ms Custer
this Custer is not
Miss Baragon for five minutes
uh thank you madam chair
um Mr Chu
Tick Tock warns users when content is
graphic or disturbing and label State
Affiliated media accounts to ensure the
viewers aren't seeing propaganda does
tick tock provide similar information to
Spanish speakers users as well as
English speakers
I believe so Congressman I I will get
back to you on that
okay and do you know if Tick Tock has
its
has a strategy for
tackling Spanish language content that
violates its trust and safety guidelines
uh we do I will get back to you on the
specifics on that
okay
uh when offensive English language
search terms or hashtags are blocked for
violating Community guidelines in
English is a Spanish translation of the
term or the hashtag automat
automatically blocked as well
I I believe so but let me check the
specifics and get back to you
do you have any idea how many people
that you might have work in a tick tock
that addresses Spanish misinformation
I know ballpark it's quite a significant
team but I can get back to you on this
thing on the details
you said significant so are you saying
it's
you have a ballpark at all you can give
us would you say it's like 10 of your
force or it's an important number so I
want to be precise and I'll get back to
you
okay do you happen to know how tick tock
how if a tick tock can effectively
ensure that Spanish-speaking users
between the ages of 13 and 17 are not
being targeted by ads promoting harmful
content
we have very strict policies for our
users who are in the teenage age group
and regardless of what language they
speak so we want to make sure that they
are given a very safe experience on our
platform regardless of the language they
well I know I'm just trying to figure
I'm trying to to ascertain resources you
may be putting into
um Spanish speaking and Spanish language
last year the Congressional Hispanic
caucus met with Tick Tock this was one
of the conversations and a source of the
discussion was addressing Spanish
language
disinformation and misinformation it
remains an urgent priority for the
Congressional Hispanic caucus as
Hispanics across the country
increasingly turned to social media
providal information we heard earlier in
this hearing that there was you know
video
um there was a tick tock post
threatening uh the chair of the
committee and it took some 40 days to
take it down so I guess I'm a little
concerned
um if you if your team doesn't have the
resources and the capability to flag
that what kind of capability is it going
to have to bring down misinformation
disinformation to Spanish speakers which
I'm assuming is a smaller fraction of
the workers that you have at tick tock
uh Tick Tock is a place for you know all
our users to come and express they're
very diverse views and you know we are
open to all ethnicities you know and
we're open to all uh everyone to come
here and express their freely expressed
reviews so it is our commitment to make
sure that the safety of those users
regardless of the language you know and
of course you know the Spanish language
user base is super important to us okay
we need to make sure that we continue to
in case you don't you don't have an
answer then okay I will look forward in
your coming you're coming back
um we've heard a lot about the the
concerns
um about children
um who may be on Tick Tock uh Mr Chu at
what age do you think it would be
appropriate for a young person to get on
tick tock we have three different
experiences here in the United States uh
there is an experience for under 13s
which is amazingly highly restricted I'm
asking what you think
would be the appropriate age to have a
child get on Tick Tock our approach is
to give differentiated experiences for
different age groups and let the parents
have these conversations with their
children to decide what's best for their
family so you think that there is a
sufficient
um safety mechanism for an
eight-year-old to be able to access Tick
Tock an Ado's experience on Tick Tock
will be so highly restricted that every
single piece of content he or she will
see will be vetted by Common Sense our
third party child safety expert and
um the the Ado will not be able to post
and the Ado will not be able to see any
personalized feed and zero advertising
in that experience so I believe yes it
is the appropriate experience for an
ideal
well then why don't you let your
eight-year-old child on Tick Tock I have
seen these news articles I would like to
address that my kids live in Singapore
and in Singapore we do not have the
under 13 experience if they lived here
in the United States I'll let them use
the under 13 experience
okay so you're saying it's because of
the country you live in it doesn't have
the same mechanisms is there a reason
you don't have those same mechanisms
everywhere
uh in in principle we want to provide
you know a good experience for our users
in general we don't we don't want to
monetize from people who are under 13.
in the US we are Copa compliant and as
part of that we were deemed as a I want
to get this specifics right I want we
will deem as a particular type of
audience makes audience app make you
want to make sure that that's right and
as a result of that we have to provide
an experience to our under 13 users in
this country as well my time is expired
thank you I yield back
yields back
which I recognized gentleman from Utah
Mr Curtis thank you madam chair uh Mr
Chu my children are getting ready to run
a marathon and I know the journey is
hearing that they'll be running for
about the same amount of time that
you'll be sitting in that chair today
unfortunately I only get you for five
minutes so instead of a marathon I'd
like to do a Sprint uh with you and I
want to I want to go back up to that 30
000 feet level
would you agree with me that section 230
was created to protect platforms like
yours from lawsuits when you distribute
information
yeah so then would you agree that
there's a line drawn between Publishers
of of information and Distributors of
information
and specifically in the section 230
language I think 230 is a very complex
topic I understand but remember it word
30 000 feet so in short your platform
distributes content that other people's
publish
one of the early Challengers to section
230 was when AOL refused to take down a
post of somebody that had
inappropriately put a phone number
associated a phone number with the
Oklahoma City bombings the courts ruled
that AOL was not liable for that post
because of section 230. now I want you
to do a hypothetical with me because I'm
going to use the Absurd to try to make a
point here let's suppose hypothetically
that AOL
instead of just posting that actually in
Madness wanted to magnify that voice and
so they took out an ad in the Wall
Street Journal linking that phone number
with Oklahoma City Bombing and let's
suppose they didn't stop there but they
went further and they took out a Super
Bowl ad linking that phone number with
Oklahoma City Bombing and let's suppose
hypothetically they didn't stop there
they sent a flyer to every home in
America linking that phone number to the
the bombing and I guess the question is
would AOL have moved from a distributor
to a publisher in this made up example
Congressman I I think respectfully I I I
think everybody can see how they would
this is not a hard question moving that
far away from the intent would have
moved them to a publisher so my question
is is
platforms are protected because they
post content but I want this room to see
not just you the protection has limits
and if AOL moves to a distributor
instead of a publisher they go outside
of those limits now let's talk
algorithms just super quickly we've
thrown that word around a lot today let
me let me here again go 30 000 feet and
we'll use another platform uh so it's so
it's not sensitive but Pinterest I like
to go on Pinterest my wife and I are
building a home working on the yard
right now if you went on my Pinterest
page you would see swing sets and things
made for my grandkids now another
hypothetical let's suppose there's some
devious intent inside Pinterest and they
decide they want to influence John
Curtis with these algorithms and they
want me to believe it's the end of the
world and all of a sudden now I'm buying
bomb shelters instead of swing sets for
my kids
have they become a publisher
and should not be protected from section
230.
and if you don't feel I'm I'm pretty
sure the room understands that they have
crossed this line and you you can tell
me if you think they have or not
uh excuse me I I will have to study that
specific example and and get it it's a
hypothetical but you can see the at some
point they've crossed the line and they
have become a publisher and a
distributor
so we've touched on this today but I
want to be super specific is it possible
that Tick Tock had enough data could get
enough data on me
that you could use artificial
intelligence and your algorithms and and
machine learning to write an algorithm
that could persuade me to change how I
view a policy issue
is that possibility exists the way we
look at it 30 000 feet where's the
Sprint I will stay very high level okay
the way we look at it is our users come
in and express whatever views they want
that's not the point the point is you
could write an algorithm that would
change and we've actually seen the
Washington Post reported the stop the
willow campaign shows how tick-tockers
are tackling climate change I think
that's all fine right and all good
unless somebody has interjected into
that and magnified or diminished voices
in that and and what I'm proposing to
you today is that that pushes them
crossed across the line from a
distributor to a publisher if they make
those decisions now serious allegations
have been made against your platform and
others many of them here today and
you're not new to these rights to these
allegations this isn't your platform but
uh some time ago there were there was an
allegation that a platform recommended
Isis related videos we've talked about
the weight loss videos we've talked
about we didn't talk about it but
they're still in the elections
whatever the motivation
I'm trying to point out that as you move
from a publisher buys you manipulate
this data with algorithms that you step
out from the protections of section 230.
do you see that logic
this is a very complex uh I understand
it's very complex but you see the logic
in your mind has Tick Tock ever stepped
across the line from a distributor to a
publisher
Congressman again this is a very complex
topic I would need to get back to him I
understand that okay and finally you
very quickly you produced a a video that
now is well known about your visit here
and today in Washington DC can you tell
me a hundred percent that no Tick Tock
employees manually manipulated that to
get more views I I checked and as far as
I know there was no boosting and heating
I went viral
organically okay Madam chair I'm sorry
I'm out of time I yield my time
gentleman yields back
five minutes
thank you madam chair uh Mr Chu as I'm
sure you know this hearing is part of an
ongoing effort by our committee to
examine data security and other concerns
with social media companies broadly and
I have to tell you I came to this
hearing interested to hear the actions
that Tick Tock is taking to combat
misinformation protect our young people
and ensure our national security but I
I'm not been reassured by anything
you've said so far and I think quite
frankly um your testimony has raised
more questions for me uh than answers
as some of my colleagues already noted
platforms like Tick Tock can easily
manipulate and undermine user autonomy
with addictive features invasive data
collection practices and disseminating
misinformation and disinformation
that's why I will be reintroducing the
detour act to mitigate this harm Mr Chu
yes or no would you oppose legislation
that banned the use of intentionally
manipulative design techniques that
trick users into giving up their
personal information
in principle it's just a yes or no in
principle I agree that that kind of
practices is not and can Tick-Tock users
opt out of targeted ads yes or no
at this moment in time we believe that
this is a very important part of the
experience yes or no time is ticking it
is an important part of the experience
if even if someone wants targeted ads um
do you give a user a clear opportunity
to prevent Tick-Tock from using tools
like pixels to collect their data and
track them off of The Tick Tock platform
we give our users a lot of tools to
control their privacy settings on our
app and by the way if you're below 16
it's private by default so you cannot
even go viral in August of 2022 response
to a letter I wrote to your company on
abortion misinformation Tick Tock
asserted several actions to address
abortion misinformation in light of
recent attacks on safe and effective
medication abortion I'm remained worried
by this misinformation and following on
Mr Getz questioning how many posts did
you actually take down that contained
abortion misinformation
contents on views on both sides of the
on abortion is allowed on a platform is
just freedom of expression if it's
dangerous misinformation we rely on
third-party experts to help us identify
and remove them I can get back to you on
specifics yes please get back with us on
the specifics
um Mr Chu in your testimony you
indicated Tick Tock has taken several
steps to implement project Texas
you've said you've spent uh in your
testimony 1.5 billion dollars you've
hired 1500 full-time employees can I ask
for some specifics about the
implementation
um this 1.5 billion dollars what was it
used for the employees were they people
that you already had that you just
transferred over and what types of roles
will they have oh okay
um this uh billion and a half US dollars
is spread across many things including
the infrastructure we have to build the
migration of the data to a new Cloud
infrastructure you know and all the
third-party security partners that we're
hiring and of course the new employees
now this team will now be run by a
gentleman who used to be this um who has
spent his career as a chief security
officer in other companies and another
gentleman who used to work I believe in
um if you could follow up with us that
would be very helpful I will because we
would really like to understand the
details where's the money going how many
people are and what will they be doing
okay you know as I put just kind of a
finer point on this one of my concerns
is that we came here hoping to hear some
actions that would alleviate some of our
concerns and our fears we got family
members we have a lot of folks here that
are constituents that are content
creators
and for us we were looking for action
we wanted to see make us feel like we
really can trust as you use the word
what I leave here with is thinking about
the fact that your company is I I
learned that you're you have
personalized data uh advertising for
kids as young as 13 and we've heard
until project Texas is supposedly stood
up engineers in China still have access
to personal data and that that means
engineers in China have access to
personal data of 13 euros in the United
States and I think that really
summarizes why you see so much
bipartisan consensus and concern about
your company and I imagine that it's not
going away anytime
General lady yields back yield to the
lady from Arizona Ms lesko for five
minutes thank you madam chair Mr Chu do
you agree that the Chinese government
has persecuted the uyghur population
congresswoman you if you use our app and
you open it you will find our users who
give all sorts of my question my
question is do you agree that the
Chinese government has persecuted the
uyghur population
well it's really concerning to hear
about all accounts of Human Rights abuse
my role here is to explain what your
platform does it's a pretty easy
question do you agree that the Chinese
government has persecuted the uyghur
population
congresswoman I'm here to discard Tick
Tock and what we do as a platform and as
a platform we allow our users to freely
Express ours on this issue or any other
issue that matters to them well you
didn't answer the question earlier today
chairman Rogers asked you and I quote
have any moderation tools been used to
remove content associated with the
uyghur genocide yes or no your answer we
do not remove that kind of content yet
in 2019 Tick Tock suspended the account
of furosa is Aziz an American 17 year
old after she put out a video about the
uyghur genocide
so your answer sir does not align with
history that particular case was a Mis
moderation I believe that video had a
picture of Osama bin Laden so we thought
it was content wise in the program I
looked it up that was a different post
that they banned I can't get back on the
specifics yes my next question
India banned the use of tick tock in
their country in 2020. New Zealand has
banned the installation of tick tock on
devices connected to the country's
parliamentary Network Canada banned the
installation of tick-tock on government
devices the United Kingdom has banned
The Tick-Tock app from government-owned
devices Belgium banned The Tick Tock
from government phones the European
Union banned the installation of tick
tock on government devices all cited
security risks with the company's data
collection in connection to the Chinese
Communist Party recently our U.S FBI
director Christopher Ray said about Tick
Tock quote this is a tool that is
ultimately within the control of the
Chinese government and it to me it
screams out with National Security
concerns Mr Chu
how can all of these countries in our
own FBI director have been wrong
I think a lot of risk that I pointed out
are hypothetical and theoretical risks I
have not seen any evidence I'm you know
eagerly weight awaiting discussions
where we can talk about evidence and we
then can address the concerns they are
being raised
yes my next question revolves around an
article India banned Tick-Tock in 2020.
a March 21st Forbes article revealed how
troves of personal data of Indian
citizens who once used Tick Tock remain
widely accessible to employees at the
company and its Beijing base parent bite
dance
a current Tick Tock employee told Forbes
that nearly anyone with basic access to
company tools including employees in
China can easily look up the closest
contacts and other sensitive information
about any user this current Tick Tock
employee also said quote if you want to
start a movement if you want to divide
people if you want to do any of the
operation to influence the public on the
app you can just use that information to
Target those groups why would a Mr Chu
why would a current Tick Tock employee
say this if it wasn't true this is a
recent article I have asked my team to
look into it as far as I know there is
we have rigorous data access protocols
this really no such thing where anybody
can get access to tools all right so I
disagree with a lot of the conclusions
Madam chair I request unanimous consent
that the Forbes March 21st 2023 article
be added to the record and I have would
like to turn over the rest of my time to
Mr Abernathy
oh thank you madam chair uh Mr Chu I'd
like to continue asking the question
that we were I ran out of time last time
so as part of project Texas you're going
to have engineers at Oracle review the
algorithms the machine learning
algorithms that Tick Tock uses to ensure
that they're free from foreign influence
but as you and I were discussing uh
reviewing the algorithms doesn't do
anything the algorithms was simple
that's not where the secret sauce is the
secret sauce is in the data used to
train them and the outcomes that you're
asking them to predict would you agree
with that no I actually believe that
with third-party monitoring you can
identify a lot of the motivation of the
code and with enough third-party expert
you can identify a lot of what the code
is designed to do but how would you how
would you uh how would you verify that
you couldn't ask the algorithm for a
different outcome than the one that uh
the the rest of the source code is
asking for the algorithm will be trained
with this again it's very technical but
it will be trained based on weights for
example and and those are things that we
can verify you know what ways you could
give us a written response to that I'd
appreciate it because I'm interested
thank you madam chair you're back
uh lady yields back gentleman General
lady yields back chair recognizes for
five minutes gentleman from Florida Mr
Soto
thank you madam chair
the genie is really out of the bottle
on this now so to speak 150 million
Americans are now on Tick Tock that's
almost half of America
they're expressing themselves in art and
music poetry short film comedy
among other Creative Expressions and
many of them are inspiring talented
young people but we also on the
committee recognize there's a darker
side to it right violence adult themes
drug and alcohol sexualization suicide
all major issues on Tech talk but also
Twitter Facebook YouTube and other
social media platforms so the solution
as I see it is to regulate Tick Tock and
other social media platforms and that
job Mr Chu as you know really Falls to
us there are real concerns bipartisan
Common Ground we've already had we had a
a federal device ban that was voted on
bipartisan in the Omnibus and uh I
co-introduced a bill with my dear friend
representative kamik about notices of
that Federal ban
um Madam chair I think the first key is
privacy we have to pass the conference
of legislation that got out of this
community but eluded Us in the last
Congress I'm really hoping we could get
that done and I'm really uh excited
about hearing that from folks the other
thing is that Tick Tock needs to be an
American company with American values
and and its ties to the Chinese
Communist party uh this is something
that'll be critical as we look and go
forward and then three we all agree we
have to protect our kids the committee
should consider Banning the use for
children under 13 of not just Tick Tock
but all social media platforms or at
least Empower parents in addition have
rules of the road for teens that are 13
to 17 so that families can do what's
right for their family so for privacy
that's on us internet privacy is on us
as far as uh being an American company
Mr Chu as you know the committee on
foreign investment in the United States
at the Department of Treasury reviews
for an investment that affects National
Security right now they've negotiated
with your company about this Oracle
setup that you've talked about servers
in an American company in America and
Texas and then Oracle would monitor the
algorithms but pressure is mounting
so Mr true would Tick Tock be prepared
to divest from bite dance and Chinese
Communist Party ties if the Department
of Treasury instructed you all to do so
a congressman I say to my opening
statement I think we are need to address
the problem of privacy I agree with you
I don't think ownership is the issue
here with a lot of respect
American Social companies don't have a
good track record with data privacy and
user security I mean look at Facebook
and Cambridge analytica just one example
so
so I I do think that you know it is not
about the ownership it is a lot about
making sure we have project taxes making
sure that we're protecting and
firewalling U.S user data from unwanted
foreign access giving third parties to
come in to have a look at this and
making sure that everybody is
comfortable we're giving transparency
and third-party monitoring and that's
what we're doing for project taxes well
I would at least encourage you all to
start having the dialogue should that be
where the present and the Congress ends
up going that the the third thing is on
on parents I had a constituent of mine
Brandy of Lake Nona say I'm a parent of
two teenagers 14 and 18 years old both
of whom have been harmed by social media
tick tocks algorithms Supply my 14 year
old son with A continuous stream of
inappropriate content and as negatively
influenced his perception of all females
I noticed the attention span of both of
my teens is change or decreased
dramatically and social media has made
my daughter insecure leading to an
eating disorder and ultimately depressed
question
what safeguards do you have and what
should we tell Brandi of Lake Nona on
about how we can help her protect her
children
we have a differentiated experience I
mentioned just now about the experience
if you're below 13 very very restricted
if you're below 13 to 17 Congressman we
actually have a whole series of things
first the content that you see you know
we make sure that we remove things that
could be mature themes from your from
your feed we also by default do not
allow under 16s to use direct messaging
we do not allow under 16s to we set the
accounts to private by default they can
go viral if you're below 18 we shut off
some features for you like for example
you're not allowed to post live streams
neither are you allowed to send virtual
gifts so we take this very seriously and
we want to continue the build to ensure
that we're giving our under 18 teenagers
on our platform although they today they
are only a minority of our of our user
base today but we still take it very
seriously Mr chair I'd encourage you to
continue thinking about how to get the
word out to parents Across the Nation on
some of these tools as well as we hear
crafter Privacy Law that will help
provide well needed regulation and
social media companies Across the Nation
thank you and I yield back gentlemen
yields back chair recognizes gentleman
from Indiana Mr Pence for five minutes
uh thank you chairwoman Rogers and
ranking member pallone for holding this
hearing I love both of your opening
remarks
like my colleagues have discussed today
are increasingly Digital World leaves
Hoosiers and all Americans in the dark
about who has access to their
information for tick tock users that
could be third-party data Brokers
advertisers or the Chinese Communist
Party Tick Tock aggressively feeds
addictive content to users to glean
massive amounts of personal data that's
worth a fortune
for Hoosiers watching at home this isn't
just ad about your favorite sports team
you know if there really are a 150
million users in the U.S this suggests
to me that the CCP has a finger on the
pulse of almost half our nation's
population I find that hard to believe
but this week I decided I would ask my
constituents in Southern Indiana to
share their stories with me went out
Monday night and we got 800 responses in
less than 12 hours okay
let me share a couple of those with you
one of my constituents shared I quote
I'm a mental health counselor most of my
teenage clients are on Tick Tock they
spend hours online being negatively
influenced by others I have seen kids
experience self-harm gender dysphoria
and many mental illnesses they have
picked up from Tick Tock I will not
allow my children to have Tick Tock the
creators know the algorithms are
addicting our children they know that
children are suffering more anxiety and
depression from screen time but they do
not care they will not change their
algorithms because it's financially
lucrative for them to keep their kids
addicted another parent said we let our
child our daughter try it out the feed
was continuously suggesting sexually
explicit stupid and vulgar videos we
discontinued it within a week and
there's been many more many more like I
said 800 okay in your testimony Mr Chu
you walk through a number of suppose
actions taken by your company to create
a safe environment Empower parents to
oversee content shown to their children
but virtually everything we've heard
reflects the opposite and some of your
some of your answers a little confusing
you know
all of those sitting here and maybe
watching on C-Span this is the 32nd
hearing we have held about privacy and
big Tech
each hearing I've been part of we've
heard the same stories about our
constituents experience and the same
promises for big Tech to do better
the truth of the matter is this
disgusting and dangerous content
littered across your platform is not
justifile viable and it's uncontrollable
Americans data is not safe and big Tech
is doing nothing to protect it putting
aside the dangers of the CCP involvement
and after these 32 hearings I believe
it's actually time to change the
narrative change the focus and change
the outcome by talking about the money
you're making at Tick Tock Mr Chu I have
a question how much revenue is generated
per user
Congressman we um private company and
you're not going to tell me does each
user receive a comparable benefit for
the amount of profit their data brings
to your company
we do share some Revenue with some
creators who produce say one minute plus
information content when am I gonna get
paid
for the data that you are selling or
you're have you're getting revenue from
advertisers when am I going to get get
paid for the data you're getting from my
children my grandchildren my neighbors I
think that's the only way to get your
attention is talk about the money you're
making and maybe that'll get you all to
do what you're supposed to do
I respect and understand your opinion
um the vast majority of our users have a
great experience I sent a video recently
as well I got hundreds of thousands of
comments but what am I getting it's a
great experience what about these 800
bad experience of people in the Indiana
six District have been getting we will
look into them and a lot of we're going
to look into you but this is my 30 this
is a 30-second big Tech hearing and
you're always going to look at it
frankly I think you're all stalling it's
what you're doing you're just trying to
buy time while you're making the 18
billion perhaps whatever you're making
I um the majority of our users have a
great experience on our platform it is
our duty to keep it safe I agree with
you that's why our commitment is to make
sure that safety I think it's priority I
think it's your duty to pay attention to
what you're doing and maybe maybe you
you paying people for the information
that you're getting from there is a way
to get that done thank you you back
gentlemen yields back chair recognizes
gentlelady from Washington Ms schreier
for five minutes
thank you for being here Mr Chu I'm
really concerned about everything that
we are hearing in this conversation
today and I appreciate your good
intentions but the actions are really
falling short as a pediatrician and the
parent of a teenager
I'm particularly concerned about how
social media generally and tick-tocks
specifically is affecting our kids and
teens we just heard a lot about this
from testimony from a psychologist
last year the American Academy of
Pediatrics sounded the alarm about our
Children's Mental Health crisis and as a
pediatrician I know this has been going
on for more than a decade in fact it
tracks perfectly with social media
engagement and during the pandemic teens
who are missing out on in-person
interactions turn to even more to social
media to connect with friends
social media is designed to be addicting
that's the business model and your
platform is the most addictive of all
and this endless mindless scrolling
takes teens away from Human
Relationships and here's what's
important it keeps teens awake all night
well past their bedtime at a time in
their lives when sleep is critical for
brain and physical development in fact
sleep deprivation alone ignoring even
content alone can cause depression
anxiety social withdrawal inattention
poor scoping skills and academic failure
um so Mr Chu I just want to follow up a
little bit on what my colleague Mr
sarbanes was discussing
um it is your business model to keep
eyes on the app to keep it addictive I
know you likely have experts who have
advised you on how to design this to
keep those eyes on your platform for the
longest possible time so I want to know
if you have psychologists or other
health experts on staff looking at
screen time hours of use and sleep
we worked with the digital Wellness lab
congresswoman and at the Boston
Children's Hospital and we came out with
a 60-minute default limit for any users
under 18. but the first to do in our
industry that is an opt-out and I can
tell you they're going to immediately
opt out it is addictive we also give
tools mean smoke or not to take the next
cigarette it is not going to happen and
by the way
um so first I have a question then I'll
go back to Boston Children's
um Mr sarbanes asked earlier
what is the percentage of teens who
actually adhere to the 60 Minute limit I
would need to check on those numbers and
get back to you I'd appreciate those
numbers I'm guessing it is an incredibly
low percentage who actually heed that
now as far as Boston Children's goes I
know you're referring to them as a
source for these ideas about gets you
know go outside get some air take some
time out
um but I can tell you as a pediatrician
I'm guessing their suggestions were a
little stronger than that and so I'm
wondering what what is the next step
what are you doing when you find out
that almost nobody is really opting out
after 60 minutes to take this burden off
of the kids and offer the parents and
change your algorithms to make them not
so hooked we give our parents as you
pointed out the family safe the family
pairing tool and in that tool if you
pair it with your teenager's phone you
can actually set a restriction how many
minutes and we believe it's very
important for parents to have these
conversations with their teenagers so
the decide what's best for their family
I also congresswoman right A lot of
people come to our platform to have a
really informative experience like I
said there were 116 billion pieces of
content on stem and we're creating a
feed dedicated to that book talk has 115
billion also heard today that well over
20 percent of the information is
misinformation we heard that about
medical remedies that are not really
remedies we've heard it about mental
health topics I mean this becomes very
dangerous especially when people who are
not trained to think very critically are
being given information and thinking
that it's true and you've said many
times that the destructive information
isn't available to kids but it is we
keep seeing examples here and so I'm
just wondering
what are you going to do with the
algorithms I mean just because you're
removing something that says anorexia
bulimia or eating disorder that doesn't
do it if you show Girls repeatedly
skinny bodies and advice on how to cook
meals that are less than 300 calories
that's dangerous we we have worked with
first of all all anything that glorifies
Eating Disorders we remove that from our
platform is violated we're working with
experts now it's a challenging problem
for our industry but we actually
Identify some identifying some of these
themes that you're talking about and
trying to build models where that kind
of content is not chained up for the
younger users so it's something we take
very seriously too we're seeing eating
disorders in elementary age kids now and
I need you to expedite that process as
much as possible because parents out
there are worried and I'm worried as a
pediatrician parents can't take
themselves off of these platforms kids
there's no way they're going to take
themselves off and we need you to do
your part it may affect your bottom line
but it could save this generation I I
assure your concerns and I commit
gentlelady yields back
chair recognizes gentleman from
Pennsylvania Mr Joyce thank you chair
Rogers and ranking member Pelon for
holding this hearing according to an
August 2022 article on the New York
Times
tick tock's in-app web browser can track
every individual keystroke made by a
user we have heard today about the
various ways in which the app's code
could be used to monitor or track users
and likewise we've heard concerns that
this data may not be fully isolated from
access by the Chinese Communist party
that said I'd like to know more about
the historical non-public U.S personal
data that your company has already
amassed Mr Chu you have publicly stated
that the non-public information of
tick-tock users in the United States is
being transferred to an oracle-based
Cloud infrastructure because of safety
concerns will that be completed by the
end of this week by the end of this
month what's the outline for
dealing with that data that you've
already amassed
uh all new data is already stored by
default in this Oracle Cloud
infrastructure with this I'm talking
about the data that you've already
amassed uh we we are in the process of
deleting what timeline will that data be
be able to be stored we will We I
believe we'll be able to get it done
this year I'm higher thank you it's not
going to occur anytime soon to be clear
until that data transfer happens user
data remains accessible to the Chinese
Communist party on March 1st of this
year the committee asks you when you
plan to delete non-public historical U.S
user data are you aware of this
Congressman I disagree with this
assessment that the Chinese government
can get access to the data is really for
uh you know this is a private company
this is what Chinese employees you
responded you responded in writing to
this committee I have the response that
we got back from you on March 7 just six
days later your attorneys wrote the
company I'm quoting the company plans to
begin the process of deleting non-public
historic U.S user data this month and
anticipates that the process will be
completed this year you came up with a
supposed plan in the summer of 2022
specifically based on our concerns that
the Communist Chinese government was
spying on U.S users but you only just
came up with the idea to delete historic
non-public U.S data just two weeks ago
let me read it again on March 7th your
attorneys wrote and I quote the company
plans to begin the process of deleting
non-public historical U.S data this
month and anticipates that the process
will be completed this year Mr Chu did
you just come up with this plan only
because we asked about it on March 1st
no we started deleting this because
that's what it looks like to me
wouldn't you agree that awaiting even
minutes for this personal privacy
protection is absolutely wrong and it is
not in the best interest of your users
uh Congressman respectfully there are
many companies that use a global
Workforce we are not the only one we are
just taking action after here given the
delay any other companies and what we've
already established about the ability of
the Chinese Communist party to access
personal user data would you agree that
no U.S government electronic devices
should have access to Tick-Tock platform
as your lackluster security currently
stands I I disagree with that
characterization like I said you think
U.S any individual should be utilizing
that on any government platform
I think the government devices should
have no social media apps to be honest
and targeted to us Mr Chu join this
hearing you have mentioned several times
that there is a quote different
experience your words for children under
the age of 13.
that is correct different experience Mr
Chu do you allow your children under the
age of 13 to participate in Tick Tock
yes or no I I did just explain this in
detail this experience doesn't exist in
Singapore or my children live if my
children lived here then yes
based on what we've heard today
it's clear to me that Tick Tock as a
company cannot be trusted and that
Americans remain significantly at risk
because of the tick tock app I still
contend that Tick Tock is the spy in
Americans Pockets I want to acknowledge
that Tick Tock does have the ability to
make those changes but unfortunately we
have not heard that from you today we
have not heard a commitment to be able
to protect the personal privacy that
Americans expect and that Americans
deserve
thank you madam chair and I yield a
remainder of my time
gentleman yields back chair recognizes
Ms Tran for five minutes
thank you madam chair
Mr Chu many big Tech CEOs have sat where
your city seated today and tried to run
out the clock during a hearing like this
one they were trained not to answer
questions and just wait for the news
cycle to pass so that they could get on
with business as usual
those same Executives want this moment
tick tock's moment under the microscope
to distract Congress and the American
people from the very real issues that
exist on their platforms you have an
opportunity to turn the tables on them
while us-based social media Giants have
regressed on protections for children
and teens on protecting our data privacy
and on embracing transparency you can
lead and you should lead last month you
announced that Tick Tock would expand
access to its researcher API but I'm
concerned that your new policy could be
more bark than bite that it won't
actually lead to the rigorous research
that we as lawmakers and that parents
and everyday Tick Tock users need in
fact your terms of service demand that
researchers delete their data at tick
tock's unilateral Direction it puts
onerous restrictions on how researchers
findings can be published and it only
allows access to public data which
researchers already have access to
within the app in order to actually
address the content moderation and
algorithmic amplification concerns that
my colleagues have raised here today and
that I've heard about directly from
parents in my home state of
Massachusetts
independent researchers not just other
tech companies like Oracle need to be
able to evaluate how tick tock's
algorithm is making decisions to promote
content
Mr Chu will you commit to expanding your
API to include data that would let
researchers investigate how your
algorithm is pushing content to users
whether it's showing up on your for you
page the hashtag page or somewhere else
we are one of the commitments I gave in
the opening statement is a commitment to
transparency and third party monitoring
so congresswoman I will look into the
details of that and get back to you and
as well as the algorithm uh including
data on what types of users were
targeted by the algorithm so that
researchers can fully understand what
content is being prioritized and who
it's being pushed to
again we have a commitment to
transparency these are very important
questions and I will get back to you on
the specifics under the same proposal
you required that researchers give Tick
Tock quote worldwide free non-exclusive
and Perpetual end quote rights to their
papers this threatens to clash directly
with well-established practices of
exclusive publication rights in research
journals Mr Chu why does tick tock need
those rights
I would need to get back to you on that
specifics if that's okay yes I I see how
we can expect researchers to do their
work under these terms and then tout
transparency uh I'm going to shift gears
with the time that I have remaining Mr
Chu I'd like to talk about tick tock's
efforts to protect children and young
users in 2021 the UK's age-appropriate
design code went into effect mandating
15 standards that companies like you
need to follow to protect children on
your platform you still operate in the
United Kingdom which means you should be
in compliance with this code so my
question is simple will you commit to
extending the protections currently
afforded children in the UK to the
millions of kids and teens who use your
app here in the United States
we take the safety of the younger users
on our platform very seriously
um every good way to prove it every
country is a little bit different in
context and in
um so let me let me look at the
specifics and bring some of the best
practices across the world but
will those best practices are in
they're being executed around the world
we just want the same for our kids here
in the United States I mean Mr Chu when
we spoke a couple of weeks ago you
indicated interest in
taking steps to earn trust our trust and
to me it hasn't happened today so far uh
but rather you've ducked behind industry
standards and comparables to your
competitors which we know are woefully
insufficient
um I strongly urge you to consider these
terms these commitments uh make the case
for why you're different from your
American competitors and do better on
than them on transparency which you've
mentioned countless times today but
which we don't really have anything
tangible to point to
yes I don't want to make excuses for our
industry of ourselves I think there's a
lot of work that needs to be done we
take this very seriously nothing is but
it's not perfect we need to keep
investing to stay ahead of our growth so
I agree that you know we need to
prioritize safety and continue to do
that as part of our company and well I
look forward to getting back your
comments and your commitments and those
uh those updated terms of service when
you write back to the committee thank
you madam chair I yield back generally
the yields back
chair recognizes gentleman from North
Dakota Mr Armstrong for five minutes
thank you madam chair you know we've
heard a lot today about the procedural
safeguards independent code review
server locations and the corporate
Independence between bite dance and the
CCP but I think there's something else a
little more telling you know when you
were asked about Chinese censorship you
pivoted immediately to drug use in
Singapore you have absolutely tied
yourself in knots to avoid criticizing
the CP ccp's treatment of the uyghur
population
and I think it begs the under it begs
the first question before we ever get to
project Texas which I'll get to in a
section if the CCP demanded that bite
dance hand over all of the data that
they had on user on U.S users in their
possession and bite dance refused I
wonder what would happen
I wonder if Jack mom might have an
opinion on that and I wonder if he'd be
allowed to give it
but let's talk about project Texas for a
second project Texas envisions a new
us-based Tick-Tock subsidiary
you have stated that this Arrangement is
unprecedented I'd argue the reason it's
unprecedented is because it requires
continual oversight monitoring by the
U.S of a private business because it
poses a national security threat the new
subsidiaries board would report to and
be approved by cypheus cypheus will also
specify hiring requirements as well as
interact with Oracle as it performs its
data role
that is an extraordinary corporate
governance structure I have questions
whether it complies with corporate law
and fiduciary fiduciary duty to
shareholders
yet the core concern is that the pro
proposes unparalleled integration with
the U.S government with a private
company which will require significant
government resources all of that to
allow a continued operation of a social
media platform that has serious National
Security implications and cepheus's
workloads already dramatically increased
in recent years with a 30 percent
increase in declarations and a 45
percent increase in joint voluntary
notices
and there's bipartisan consensus that
cypheus needs to be expanded as we speak
the only Mr Chu can you identify any a
similar corporate Arrangement that
requires federal government to expand
such resources to monitor an alleged
data privacy and National Security risk
Congressman I'm not an expert on this
matter I believe that there are certain
similar Arrangements but I I'm not the
expert on this matter well the only one
I could find was the UK created the
Huawei cyber security evaluation center
in 2010 to assess huawei's Tech and to
detect malicious activity and guard UK's
networks that's worked so well that the
United Kingdom is now planning on
kicking Huawei out of Great Britain
you stated that Tick Tock has invested
1.5 billion dollars in Project Texas are
you aware of any discussions or
proposals that entail Tick-Tock that
entail tick funding or offsetting the
costs of cypheus role
those discussions are I need to get back
on you on the specifics but I can tell
you yes we did spend approximately one
and a half billion US Dollars on our
side you spent one and a half billion
dollars on Project Texas but do you have
any I mean you agree that if sypheus
takes on this role they're going to need
a massive influx of dollars in Human
Resources right
I cannot speak on behalf of serious
Congressman should the U.S government
expend such resources to create this
extraordinary arrangement for tick tock
especially considering alleged data
privacy and National Security risks
Congressman I cannot speak on behalf of
the you know the project Texas doesn't
work without cypheus
right project project Texas as you guys
have proposed it does not work without
cepheus involvement the idea behind
project Texas is the firewall of U.S
user data make sure it's stored by an
American company overseen by American
personnel and we will invite third party
monitors to to monitor this so that in
essence in at least as far as I know is
the majority of the costs because it
will rely on not just us building the
infrastructure but us you know Finding
and hiring these third-party monitors
who are vetted to come in and monitor
this structure
you talked earlier about the uh
shareholders uh ownership of tick tock
and you said 60 Global Investors 20 is
employees and 20 is original Founders
are all those voting shares the same
no the founder has waited voting Rises
is common in our industry so do as far
as a voting block of sheriffs owned and
bite danced do you know if the Chinese
Communist party not Chinese government
Communist Party officials the Chinese
condominance party do you know what
their percentage of the actual voting
block share of bite dances
Communist Party does have voting rights
and bite dance Chinese Communist party
members is a different question I I do
the founders control the voting block of
by dances shares I do know that the
founder himself is not a member of the
Communist party but we don't know the
political affiliation of our employees
because that's not something we ask
does the Chinese government know the
political affiliation of their Chinese
citizens
I cannot answer that question on their
behalf I yield back
gentleman yields back yield to the lady
from General lady from New Hampshire
Miss Custer five minutes
thank you madam chair uh Mr true I just
want to say I agree with all of the
comments of many of my colleagues today
that we need to take a close look at
whether Tick Tock poses a national
security risk
for today I'm going to focus my limited
time on how Tick Tock can better protect
its youngest users and I think a number
of us have identified as parents today
and have serious concerns as we relate
to you just this week I heard from a
parent in my district in Nashua New
Hampshire whose child was served harmful
content on Tick Tock and has needed
counseling as a result this experience
is not unique to this family and it
underscores the need for better child
protections on your app I'd like to dig
further into tick tock's current safety
and privacy controls for children
I understand that Tick Tock restricts
certain app capabilities for users under
age 18 and has additional restrictions
for users under age 16 or 13 such as
limiting who can interact with them on
the platform however these protections
are worthless if any Savvy child can
easily bypass these age restrictions by
deleting their own account and creating
a new one with a different age and by
easily I mean you can literally go in
and open another account using the same
email address
so I've been made aware by child safety
groups including fair play for kids and
common sense that it is that simple for
young users to bypass the age
restrictions on Tick Tock yes or no are
you aware of this issue
I apologize I think that's a great uh
issue question that you raised if a user
implementation is blocked my
understanding is that if the user tries
to do it again within a short period of
time and I won't disclose we did it in
our office yesterday you can go right
back in use the exact same email address
and open a new account so can I get your
commitment that you will at least fix
that bug I will go and have a look at it
thank you
um
if if we're here today to talk Tick Tock
and not other platforms but I'm happy to
look at legislative Solutions in the
interim Tick Tock has a responsibility
to do more to protect its young users
and I will accept your commitment to
take a look at fixing that issue
will you
um
let's see sorry I recognize that Tick
Tock has made efforts to provide parents
and guardian increase options to Monitor
and limit their child's activity on the
app including family pairing and time
limit features but I still have concerns
in order to access family pairing
parents then must download the app onto
their phone and this sounds like a
design to lure more users onto the app
rather than a practical safety future
furthermore downloading the app may not
be a viable option for many patients uh
parents Mr Chu will Tick Tock commit to
developing other methods for parents to
monitor their child's use of the app
without having to download the Tic Tac
app on their phone
I I can look into that specifically and
get back to you but the family parrot
that you mentioned is is a very good
tool that we develop I encourage parents
with teenagers too it's not up to use a
tool and let me just say one of my
concerns is that um the minimum time
limit Tick Tock lets parents set for
their children is 40 minutes which for a
young child is a very long period of
time actually giving parents control
would mean providing them the freedom to
set the screen time that makes sense for
their family now I've got a copy of the
app page that shows just the four
options would you commit to adding and
other option so that the parent can
easily set their own screen time limit
I can take a look at that I think it's
important I think parents are looking
for control they're looking to
allow their family to use these apps
without Tick Tock taking over
um their child's media use I've heard
use reports I've heard reports of users
struggling to access the feature and so
I will look forward to hearing back from
you on adding an other so that a parent
can add a custom limit
so finally I ask that you commit to
report back to this Committee in the
American public on how Tick Tock
addresses these safety issues and the
steps that you are taking to default
children's accounts to the most
protective possible settings and with
that Madam chair I yield back gentlelady
yields back I yield to Cherry yields to
the gentleman from Ohio five minutes Mr
balderson
okay
thank you madam chair thank you Mr Trent
for being here today
um I would like to start by inserting it
into the record a report entitled Tick
Tock bite dance and their ties to the
Chinese Communist party which was
published by the Australian Parliament
just over a week ago if I could add that
to the record objections so ordered
thank you madam chair Mr Chu
we know that your company's algorithm
has been exposed for delivering videos
to China that encourages them to develop
Eating Disorders promotes challenges
that have caused children to
accidentally commit suicide glorifies
the use of drugs and pornography
despite the constant media coverage of
this issue your company continues to
feed our children this dangerous and
harmful content
can you explain to parents back at my
congressional district why it should be
their burden and not tick tocks to set
up that Guardian parential controls for
their children so that they do not view
content which encourages Eating
Disorders or committing suicide
Congressman I take this uh issues very
seriously if the user is between is a
teen issues on our platform we actually
have a differentiated experience
including certain models that we're
building with experts to help identify a
certain content that's not inherently
harmful but could could lead people to
eating disorders anything that glorifies
Eating Disorders is is violative of our
platform and we remove that and I want
to assure you that I take this very very
seriously this commitment okay
Mr Curtis my colleague mentioned the use
of heating tool on your platform to make
specific videos go viral or get more
views this Tick Tock use a choline tool
where employees can manually limit the
amplification of content that Tick Tock
should hide like content that promotes
Eating Disorders drug use or suicide
among children
the only promotion tool that we have is
approved by the local teams so in the US
by the U.S team and it's for commercial
purposes like
like Taylor Swift you know I think when
she onboard it we you know yes or no
my uh I just want to make sure that I'm
answering your question with specifics
um
if this toy exists why isn't it being
used to call then uh the spread of
dangerous content I mean why is it still
happening a dangerous content has uh um
that violates we we remove them when we
see them we actually remove them from
the platform
okay uh the fact of the matter here is
that despite whatever action you take
that Tick Tock is taking to protect
teams your algorithm continues to
promote harmful content wouldn't you
agree that indicates there is something
inherently wrong with the algorithm your
platform employs
I I do respectfully disagree with that
the algorithm drives a great user
experience for many many users well I
talked about stem content that has 116
billion views on our platform I want one
more example book talk is a trend that
happened on our platform is to encourage
people to read and globally it has 115
billion views and it's fantastic I've
heard people telling me that they are
reading more because of book talk so
there is a lot of good and joy and
positive that can be derived from The
Tick Tock experience yes there are some
bad actors who come in and post
violative content and it's our job to
remove them but the overwhelming
experience is a very positive one for
our community
but if it's your job to remove them it's
been said many times here today about
the 41 days that that video stood up
with addressing Mrs the Cherub woman
after this I'm going to go and look into
the specifics
um of um of that all right thank you
Madam chair yield back
gentlemen yields back chair recognizes
the lady from Texas Miss Fletcher for
five minutes
thank you chairwoman Mick Morris Rogers
and thanks to ranking member pallone for
holding today's hearing and thank you Mr
Chu for appearing today it's been a long
day but we're here to learn about a
complex set of issues that relate to
Tick-Tock and how to address them I
think that's what we're hearing from
colleagues on both sides of the aisle
today is a real effort to Grapple with
the challenges that we see for National
Security and for the safety and
protection of American citizens
especially our children and young adults
and we've already covered today a lot of
um the the information about the
extensive use of the app the number of
users who are children and young adults
but I think it Bears repeating as Mr VC
mentioned that Tick Tock is the
preferred platform of Young Americans
and they use it for all kinds of
creative and important things and we
have seen that but there are also some
dangerous things that we know it has and
continues to be used for and that also
that the data that's collected is posing
additional dangers and that's that's
what we're here for most people using
Tick Tock do not realize that Tick Tock
is collecting data about their
keystrokes or about their browsing
history on other sites and so much more
um and I agree with my colleagues that
we need a comprehensive set of data
privacy laws here in the country and
we've heard some very good ideas today
Mr Chu you've mentioned several times
today that these are industry-wide
issues and I agree with you that there
are industry-wide challenges here but
there are also some specific things
relating to tick tock that I want to
focus my questions on and really want to
understand where there's a difference
and how we can craft legislation that
addresses the very real challenges that
we've been hearing about today
um as you know States across the country
have joined an ongoing investigation
into possible violations of consumer
protection laws by Tick Tock as they
pertain to tick tock's effect on the
mental health of American children and
teenagers
as part of this investigation states
have requested to review internal
Tick-Tock Communications that takes
place on Lark right that's tick tock's
primary instant messaging system is that
right
yes okay and does every tick tock
employee have a lark account
it is very similar to companies that use
slack or any other instant messaging
tool but Lark is a proprietary instant
messaging tool it's not slack it is
something that was developed by by dance
it was developed by Tick Tock no it's
developer but
it's developed by bike dance okay and
and so a couple
poking from that is it true that Lark
video conferencing has a translation
feature in which Chinese has translated
to English text and vice versa
that is correct it helps with global
inter cooperation okay and um and those
translated conversations are somehow
saved into the Lark system
we need to get back to you on the
specifics
um uh there is um you know I'll get back
to you on the specifics okay that would
be great to know and I I neglected test
but does every tick tock employee have a
lark account
yes I believe so yes including you do
you have one yes I believe so
um and um and then do you have a there's
some kind of profile for your instant
messaging system so every employee
identifies their manager and and their
Department who they work for what they
do is that all included in their log
profile do you know it's very common for
companies to have
Enterprise messaging tools that's all
companies use it does and I guess I'm
asking specific definitely about Lark
since it's specific to tick tock whether
it includes information like identifying
who for example your manager is do you
know whether that's something that's
identified in lark
uh yes again some of these HR features
are built into a lot of Enterprise tools
that we use and yeah so like for your
own profile does it identify who your
manager is yes it does and who does it
identify as your manager I report to the
CEO of bydance okay and so that is
[Music]
um
is that identified as your manager
that's the former CEO he has stepped
down from the board and as the CEO yes
okay so Mr rubo is identified now as
your manager on by on um on yes the
system okay
um and as you mentioned it was developed
by bite dance so it's not just used by
Tick Tock
um employees it's also used by dancing
plays is that right also by other
companies now I think Lark is selling it
then it's um it's a good tool for
instant messaging so Lark is available
to third parties outside of the by dance
system as well like
um and do you personally ever use Lark
to communicate with bike dance
with uh employees at bike dance yes I do
you do okay
um well I'm running out of time and I'm
sorry to say because this is really
interesting
um I do think it underscores some of the
concerns that have been raised in this
hearing um so I think it's clear we have
work we need to continue to do here in
the Congress to adjust data protection
and privacy and um with that Madam
chairwoman I thank you and I will yield
back
gentlelady yields back committee stands
in recess and will reconvene immediately
following the third vote being called
okay
yeah
first steps
um
that's my plan I'm sticking with it
but it's not over yet
wow
[Music]
they called Skipper sunshine
Sunshine
um
[Music]
thank you
very much
absolutely
thank you
very much
[Music]
thank you
very much
foreign
[Music]
thank you
I can see his numbers
is
today
[Music]
two apologies
listening
um
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
anyways
foreign
thank you
yeah
[Music]
thank you
man
okay thank you people
um
so the parents that were highlighted by
the Rockies
um
I don't know if there's any questions
you may just make a statement but
they'll be accompanied by their attorney
so I told them after he Departed foreign
[Music]
right now
upstairs
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you foreign
thank you
[Music]
apart
I think I like to take cups
foreign
[Music]
thank you
the music
yes
possible
together
[Music]
organizations
foreign
oh
yeah
thank you
okay
yeah wrap it up yeah
father
um
[Music]
lightning round
s
that's great
um
I haven't had a life
reviews
[Music]
yes
we're back
thank you so now we
now before you go
[Music]
yeah
no problem
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
okay
friends
together
[Music]
I think that we ordered you know or if
there's a valid legal order so okay
several reports hearings and leaked
internal documents have indicated that
Tick Tock has repeatedly censored or
deamplified
content that is critical Chinese
Communist parties party party policies
in the U.S and abroad are you aware of
those reports I don't think that's
accurate Congressman or do not are you
aware of those reports there could be
some reports that say that but that that
action itself is not your testimony here
today is that you can keep up with stuff
and make it as clean as possible quote
unquote are you aware of those reports I
want to make it very clear that
that's great and fun there is content
that's critical of China
are you aware of the reports citing that
fact
uh again like I said the fact is if you
go onto our platform you will find
content that is critical of China well
we're going to talk about that now this
committee is looking at reforming
section 230 230 of the communication
decency act which has already been
mentioned here today
do you think that censoring history and
historical facts and current events
should be protected by section 230's
good faith requirement
a congressman that that is a more
complex topic I would need to speak to
my team and get back to you on the
specifics is your team behind you
uh it's uh my broader team I will speak
to them it's always good to have folks
behind you isn't it
not them no oh okay I got you here are
my concerns with Tick Tock your claims
are hard to believe it's no secret to us
that Tick Tock is still under the thumb
of CCP influence and let's be honest
Tick Tock is indocting our children with
divisive woke and pro-ccp propaganda all
while threatening our national security
with Chinese spyware in fact in fact let
me look at my notes Here you had an
exchange with uh Anna issue in your
exchange would Congressman FSU you said
that quote Extreme Fitness videos
shouldn't be viewed too much you
remember that Exchange
here today
um what extremious video was would Anna
issue out of California
I any content that is um has extremist
content okay it's not allowed on our
platform it will be we identify them was
that also true about the gun video that
you saw today
was that extreme content that should
have been taken down I would need to
look at the specifics of the whole video
there was a bit of lag just now we
couldn't see the whole video okay you
know it threatened our our committee
chair here that is unacceptable okay you
know you're aware of that extreme video
and why did it take 40 plus days to get
it down does it take literally an act of
Congress should we plan to have a
Committee hearing every time every day
every time there's something brought up
so that we
can limit the content on Tick Tock
should Congress plan to do that Mr shoe
Congressman um we work very hard to
remove violative content on our platform
okay well let me let me move on with
chrome Mr Heston he asked you about your
wages and your stocks and you said
you're Pro you prepare you prefer to
keep that information private now you
know how we feel about American
public's information we prefer to keep
it private as well we don't think Tick
Tock does that
so Madam chair my time is up
and if this committee gets its way tick
tock's time is up
you don't terrified me get my response
to an earlier question gentlemen um I'm
sorry gentleman's time has expired or
yeah uh our chair recognizes Mr Ruiz
from California for five minutes thank
you chair Rogers I echo my colleagues
concerns about tick tock's impacts on
the health and well-being of the
American public as a doctor and the
ranking member of the select
subcommittee on the coronavirus pandemic
I am troubled that Tick Tock is Rife
with medically inaccurate information
including dangerous misinformation and
the intentional disinformation about
covid-19 and vaccines tick tock's
Community guidelines state that the
common company will remove content or
accounts that involve quote misleading
information that causes significant harm
unquote however since the early stages
of the pandemic Tick Tock has been used
as a platform for people pushing
misinformation disinformation including
by those casting doubt on the safety and
efficacy of life-saving vaccines and
despite tick tock's pledge to address
harmful misinformation these videos are
being viewed millions of times for
example The Institute for strategic
dialogue found that a sample of 124 Tick
Tock videos containing vaccine
misinformation were viewed 20 million
times
and Media Matters found that a sample of
18 videos with kova 19 misinformation
were viewed over 57 million times
here's another shocking study the
Journal of American medical informatics
Association found that when searching
hashtag quote coronavirus on Tick Tock
almost 30 percent of the videos that
came up contained misinformation videos
in that sample containing a high level
of misinformation were viewed a median
of
9.4 million times Mr true what are these
why are these dangerous videos falling
through the cracks of your company's
efforts to enforce its own Community
guidelines and remove harmful
misinformation uh before before I answer
that in my response
Mr shoe you're in my time answer my
question I I understand but if I would
like to clarify some clarified I have
five minutes okay in my time you're in
my time now answer my question yes uh
any dangerous misinformation is part we
partner with third-party experts to be
able to identify and help us with
subject domain expertise and with the
expertise that we recognize we rely on
those to develop policies to recognize
and remove concrete your efforts are
have failed and they're dangerous
okay it's public health risks that
you're putting millions of people's
lives at risk for not being able to do a
better job and I'm concerned that tick
tock's features make it users uniquely
vulnerable to the spread of this
misinformation for example Tick Tock
makes it extremely easy to reuse audio
and videos to create content which
allows misinformation to quickly spread
through the platform and tick tock's
algorithm to recommend videos means that
a user viewing one video containing
misinformation can easily result in
their quote unquote for you page
becoming filled with videos containing
similar misinformation this is a
dangerous feedback loop so is Tick Tock
taking any action to modify these
features so that they no longer
facilitate the spread of this
misinformation or this misin information
feedback loop Congressman again like I
said any dangerous miss or
disinformation we work with third
parties to recognize that and it's
proactively removed from our platform
okay so it doesn't need to get into
those Loops so I so I can I can go back
and read you these the data and the and
uh the Journal of American medical
informat informatics 30 of videos uh
after searching for hashtag coronavirus
had misinformation one like almost one
out of three your third party and your
and your company are missing one almost
one out of three misinformed videos so
you're telling me what you're doing I'm
telling you the data shows that you are
grossly failing at that effort the other
thing the other question I have for you
is a tick tocks is also in Spanish and
Spanish-speaking populations have been
specifically targeted to uh to
misinformation uh when it comes to many
aspects especially medical
misinformation and as chair of the
Congressional Hispanic caucus we reached
out to you last Congress on this issue
so what is your intent or how does your
your
team look like to address Spanish versus
English how many staff do you have
focusing on Spanish versus how many
staff do you have focusing on English
misinformation
Congressman um I was like I'd explain
just now
um the Spanish-speaking population is
very important to our platform we do
have a lot of Spanish-speaking
moderators and we will continue to how
many Spanish-speaking staff versus
English-speaking space staff for
misinformation do you have
I can get back to you on the specifics
but miss dangerous misinformation is
moderated regardless of language
not to the degree that it needs to be
we are we can continue to work hard when
there's misinformation people base their
decisions that oftentimes put them at
risk in exposures and their families at
risk and with the coronavirus especially
prior to the vaccines uh they they the
risk was their life
thank you real bad Madam chair I would
like to clarify something in the
follow-up question to representative
dance question just now I misunderstood
the follow-up about bite then spying
um on on behalf of the Chinese
government my answer to that question
should be a no because it came very
rapidly I just want to clarify that
gentleman's time is expired
gentlemen are the chair chair recognizes
the gentleman from
uh Idaho Mr Folger for five minutes
thank you madam chairman
Mr Chew we've been going a long time
here by now and a lot of questions have
been answered and
a lot of them have not been answered and
primary thing I want to do is just share
some thoughts of what I've seen
learned today been exposed to
first of all I've got to compliment you
on
having a a product that's impressive
it is a very influential tool
it is it is addictive and that's what
you want users to be exposed to
something addictive and it is a data
Gathering
masterpiece
so clearly
it's got the potential to sell products
connected like-minded people with that
artificial intelligence
um capability in a viral viral fashion
and perhaps spread information quicker
better than anything else that's been
developed out there
now I'm just going to tell you I'm not a
subscriber at least a willing subscriber
but probably in that database somewhere
is my preferences with
colors or Foods or
who I've spoken to or what I've said
they're my favorite newspapers I don't
know
but that's available
to be sold or given to
whomever or whatever and the whatever is
what
bothers me
and I'll use myself as an example again
if for whatever reason I became a Target
in this I became somebody you didn't
like and I know it'd be hard to believe
because you gotta like me
but let's say you didn't
or your company didn't or for whatever
reason I became an app app Target
that artificial intelligence algorithm
could be shared or spread selectively
to a targeted audience that with
negative information that
maybe they has been paired up
with that knowledge and that app to make
me look really really bad
or to the converse
same thing could be done
to make me look really really good
here's the problem
it's someone else or some artificial
intelligence algorithm that has
inordinate power
to subjectively combine strategic data
with strategic audiences to shape
whatever thoughts and news they want
and I've equipped it not even known it
that process could apply to anyone or
anything there's the danger it could be
the president United States it could be
their kids it could be a company could
be a political party could be a news
Outlet anything could be targeted for
that selective viral spread of just some
information
Mr Chu this may be genius
but that doesn't make it fair it does
make it good and it doesn't make it
accountable
I wouldn't want my government to have
that ability
I wouldn't want a company or a political
party or my friend August here or my
mother to have that capability
I certainly don't want
that to be accessible
to anyone in China
now there's no question it's got immense
value
and as proof of that you're here
because this hasn't been a fun day I
know that
hasn't been a fun day for us either
artificial intelligence is
difficult to manage once it's on auto
cruise control and it's as we've talked
about nearly impossible to wall off data
I know the idea
no Little Dot databases
I know a little bit about Corruption of
those databases it's very difficult to
wall things off
and in unfortunately
there's this thing in College Human
Nature where there's some dark
components from time to time there's
always a temptation to monetize things
or
perhaps use some of these tools for
nefarious purposes and they can have
absolutely devastating consequences
so Mr Chu I'm going to wrap up my my
comments and just say that
this is so attractive Tick Tock poses as
a Mr Rogers Neighborhood
but it acts like big brother
and it's got to stop
Madam chair the gentleman yield
gentleman yields back gentleman yield
oh gentleman yields yield to uh Mr
Morgan Griffith
I thank the gentleman for yielding uh Mr
Chu earlier we had submitted into
evidence The Tick tight bite dance and
their ties to the Chinese Communist
Party report that was filed as an
exhibit last week with the senate in
Australia
if you have any comment I'd like to get
it on this paragraph out of their
summary our research confirms Beyond any
plausible doubt that Tick Tock is owned
by bite dance bite dances a PRC company
and bite dance is subject to all the
influence guidance and de facto control
which the Chinese Communist party now
subjects all PRC technology companies we
show in this report how the CCP and the
PRC state agencies together the party
State have extended their ties into bite
dance to the point that the company can
no longer
be accurately described as a private
Enterprise you keep calling it a private
Enterprise but all the countries in the
world are saying it's not a private
Enterprise it's part of the Chinese
Communist party what say you sir yes or
no is it part of the Chinese Communist
party as everybody thinks or are you
still living in some mystical world
I disagree with many conclusions you're
living in the midst of the world I yield
back
someone yields back chair recognizes
the lady gentle lady from Minnesota Miss
Craig for five minutes
well thank you so much Madam chair for
yielding Mr Chu I'm I'm probably like a
lot of parents uh who are also members
of Congress out here I know
um
a number of us when you testified
earlier today you mentioned that the
over 35 segment was a growing uh group
of potential users um as if over 35 is
old and I realize that my own children
think that I'm ancient are four boys but
like a lot of us up here we understand
that there is
some potential good and of course many
of your influencers are doing
what they're doing for all the right
reasons
but
one thing in your testimony you said a
lot
was safety
but as a mother and as a member of
Congress and as someone
who's very concerned about drug use in
our country I was surprised that that
didn't come up once in your testimony no
real reference to it
here today you know I've raised my
concerns in general about social media
platforms serving as an illegal
Marketplace for drugs in Prior big Tech
hearings and I plan to continue that
Focus during today's hearing
Mr to a March 8 2023 article in the
Washington Post detailed the fact that
Tick Tock has made little progress in
combating the sale of illegal drugs on
your platform
in fact Colorado attorney general Phil
Weiser said that getting drugs on
platform like yours was nearly as
convenient as using a phone to order a
pizza or call an Uber
that same article mentions that law
enforcement agencies have been
frustrated by tick tock's lack of
competition in the form of data sharing
in my view Tick Tock has taken little
action in response to this crisis
according to a May 2022 blog post from
Tick Tock you donated 125 000 or
0.001 of your 22 Revenue to an anti-drug
effort on your platform in the form of
AD credits you also redirected hashtag
drugs hashtag Fentanyl and other obvious
hashtags away from post selling drugs to
a community resources page as if a
teenager looking for drugs is going to
look for them at hashtag drugs
drug dealers have easily worked their
way around this using emojis and slang
to communicate that they have drugs for
sale to this day it is possible for
anyone to log into your platform and
acquire drugs and the consequences of
that can be fatal
what are you doing to move past these
token efforts to prevent teenagers from
accessing drugs on your platform look as
parents up here today we not we may not
understand everything about your
platform I'm not an a tech Guru many of
us up here may not use exactly the right
language but we know when our kids are
at risk and our kids are at risk on your
platform so what are you going to do to
move past these previous token efforts
um congresswoman we do take illegal
illegal drugs some content on our
platform very seriously it violates our
guidelines we proactively identify and
move them and as you pointed out if
anybody searches for any drugs on our
platform we do Point them to point them
to resources to help them with that at
the same time we have also taken product
changes like for example we don't allow
our under 16 users to use direct
messaging and the reason is because you
know we wanted to there was a trade-off
here and we believe that you know it
will protect these younger users better
from getting con from getting contacts
from people trying to push illegal
activity so we will continue to work on
it again no company can be perfect at
this we're not saying Mr Chu I I with
all due respect the no company can be
Turf perfect line
has been used way too much today I'm
going to reclaim my time you know
clearly in the three plus hours you've
been before us today
what you're saying about project Texas
just doesn't pass the smell test
my constituents are concerned that Tick
Tock and the Chinese Communist Party are
controlling their data and seeing our
own vulnerabilities
if you're an American company we could
look at your 10K we could see who your
shareholders are the answer you provided
earlier today you'd rather not tell us
what your compensation is or how it's
derived well no American CEO would like
to tell us that
but they have to because they're an
American company so what you're doing
down in Texas
it's all well and good but it is not
enough for us to be convinced
that our privacy is not at risk so how
can you say that you're protecting
American users privacy with the CCP
being so heavily involved with bike
dance it's not possible
China won't even carry your product
how is it that you can convince us
that our privacy is not at risk and more
than that our kids privacy is not at
risk in this country
in my opening statement
thank you madam General ladies time is
expired we're going to have to continue
on
gentleman from Georgia Mr Allen's um
recognized for five minutes
thank you madam chair and thank you Mr
chief for being here today
September 2021 The Wall Street Journal
published an article titled how Tick
Tock serves up sex and Drug videos to
minors
this article gives a chilling depiction
of the types of content that tick tock's
algorithm is curating for our children
this article claims that your
application served an account that was
registered as a 13 year old quote videos
about drug use referenced uh in
reference to to cocaine meth addiction
and promotional videos for online sales
of drugs the algorithm was also found to
have delivered countless videos uh
depicting quote pornography and other
adult content
uh to the device of an account that was
registered as a 13 year old could you
please explain to the members of this
committee and parents across the country
why your company deems it acceptable for
such inappropriate content to be
prominently featured on a child's for
you page
the a lot of the content that you
mentioned congressmen are violative of
of our own policies and we are we don't
think they're acceptable and we will
remove them when we identify them we
take this very seriously I mentioned
this this is an industry-wide challenge
we're investing as much as we can we
don't think it represents the majority
of the user's experience on Tick Tock
but it does happen
um some Bad actors try and come in and
post some of this content and we're
doing our best to invest as much as you
can to remove them
well I would say you're not doing enough
I have 14 grandchildren Mr true
you personally believe that such content
is appropriate for minor children to
consume
a lot of the content that you mentioned
like porn for example is not allowed on
our platform so no I do not think that
acceptable for young people to consume
earlier this week the Wall Street
Journal published an article titled
quote tick tock's Chinese partner has
another another wildly popular app in
the US this app is called cap cut
is a video editing tool to help users go
viral on Tick Tock while for obvious
reasons most of our attention is focused
on Tick Tock and bike dance other
companies and their applications are
also continuing to exploit the privacy
of Americans
Tick Tock cap cut
Lark face you all of these apps are also
controlled by by bite dance and prose
serious privacy concerns in 2022 it's
reported that top Buzz an international
version of bite dance censored Chinese
news app was used to spread pro-china
messages to Americans
when it comes to the data privacy of
Americans we must have a clear set of
guidelines to ensure Americans data is
protected and not passed along to
unknown third-party actors who could
pose a threat to our security
I urge my colleagues to continue to work
together to pass a National Data privacy
Bill not just one out of the house
Energy and Commerce Committee but also
through the house of this Congress it is
the only systematic way we can address
privacy concerns unfortunately I've been
given no reason to believe that
Tick-Tock does not pose a threat and
cannot be trusted to follow our laws
when they conflict with the desires of
the Chinese Communist Party
your firewall that you're talking about
uh if you had a bad actor in your
um what you call your Texas
uh initiative
could get through that firewall and send
any information that they wanted to send
anywhere
direct to the and to directly
party
would you deny that
Congressman this risk that you talk
about exists for every company Bad
actors I'm talking about Tick Tock sir
in fact the risk is lower for us because
it is a risk correct the the Personnel
will be vetted so there is actually
lower than most companies in the
industry
well that is why we have to deal with
your company and uh with that uh Madam
chair I yield back
John holds back chair recognizes the
gentleman from California Mr Peters for
five five minutes
thank you madam chair Mr Chu thanks for
being here today uh
you know your testimony discusses an
effort your company has named project
Texas
and the Investments your company has
made in creating a firewall between the
United States user data and entities in
China
susceptible to influenced by China's
government and with your company's
recent Announcement by cepheus
uh that that syphus has instructed Tick
Tock to separate itself from bite dance
or face a ban tick tock's commitment to
retaining this firewall is at a
Crossroads so I want to ask you some
questions about your company's long-term
plans to ensure the safety and security
of American data and this for me is the
Crux of the concern for me about tick
tock first of all does the Chinese
government need to approve projects to
project Texas for tick tock to agree to
it
Congressman we have designed project
taxes to move forward in the United
States this is something that we have
described at length in the written
testimony and in my opening statement
the firewall of American data stored on
American soil by an American company
overseen by American Personnel this this
is designed to move forward in the
United States but does the Chinese
government need to approve project Texas
for you to agree to it we do not believe
so um
how is Tick Tock considering the future
of project Texas in the event of a sale
or other ownership changes are there
elements of the project Texas The
tick-stock Tick Tock would change prior
uh prior to or
I cannot speak on this hypothetical or
on you know yeah on potential you know
owners who I cannot represent
okay you don't know
I don't know yes uh despite project
Texas's plan positive changes it does
include several broad exceptions that
would allow large amounts of U.S user
data to routinely lead the country
I don't want to know a little bit more
about these exceptions so I can
understand whether project Texas can
live to UPS up to its promise protecting
Americans user user data I understand
that under project Texas business data
and public data will be permitted to
regularly leave the United States is
that correct
um almost all the data is under the
that's not public it's under the
definition of protected data this
accepted data that you mentioned I can
get back to your team on this is really
for interoperability purposes to make
sure that the business can still operate
and American users are still getting the
benefit can you tell us what data where
the data goes and how it's used by the
company it will travel outside of the
United States but I can get back to you
on the specifics it's data that doesn't
it cannot be used to identify users you
know so it really is data that ensures
the interoperability of the platform and
understand that I think we would want we
would want to have some understanding of
how how we would distinguish that by
definition and then also how it would be
enforced I can get back to you on those
specifics how is the U.S data used to
promote certain content back in the
United States market for instance
I'm sorry so
um
what you have a U.S us data feed right
um how can you discuss when you discuss
where the data goes and how it's used by
the company how and at what points of
data transfer does the US data feed the
PRC develop algorithm used by tick tock
how would the data that you're talking
about we take talk does not it's not
available in in China
the PRC developed algorithm used by Tick
Tock how does U.S data get fed by that
the U.S the algorithm that leads to the
US app is in the Oracle Cloud
infrastructure and is trained by us and
global data again Tick Tock does not
it's not available in mainland China
how can we trust that these exceptions
for project Texas won't be used abused
by China's government or by Foreign
adversaries we can we this is the fourth
commitment transparency third-party
monitors including the definitions of
this exceptions and you know we want we
can be very transparent on how they're
used okay I guess I guess my question
will be that you want to get back to me
in writing that's fine but how he would
distinguish between the data for
interoperability that you suggest needs
to be chaired with what data wouldn't be
shared yeah it's um again you know it's
um first of all public data it's not
part of the protected data definition
because public data is what users want
to share globally so if we post a video
and you want someone in France to see it
just by definition it has to leave the
United States otherwise the world cannot
see it now there are certain aggregated
and anonymized data sets that's useful
for interoperability for for advertising
for example and that is um part of what
we're talking about right I can get back
to you on the specifics but I think we'd
also want to know how it's anonymized
and how what what oversight and
enforcement we can count on okay I can
get back to you on specifics thank you
are yield back gentlemen yields back
gentleman from Texas Mr fluger's
recognized for five minutes thank you
madam chair uh Mr Chu I got to hand it
to you you've actually done something
that in the last three to four years has
not happened except for the exception of
maybe Vladimir Putin you have unified
Republicans and Democrats
and if only for a day we're actually
unified because we have serious concerns
uh do you does tick tock support good
I mean this Tick Tock a platform for
good just yes or no I believe yes okay
uh does tick tock support freedom of
speech
yes it's one of the commitments I've
given this committee do you personally
support the First Amendment
um Congressman I'm here as the CEO of
tick tock I'm here to talk about Tick
Tock as the CEO of tick tock do you
think supports Freedom
um does tick tock support genocide
again Congressman I'm here to talk about
take talks Tick Tock support genocide
does tick tock no okay thank you but uh
reclaiming my time
um I'm gonna go to a a video uh now and
it's from in his Canter freedom and I'd
like you to see NS Canter Freedom who
has spent his entire career post MBA
fighting against human rights violations
in within the Chinese Communist party go
ahead and play this video which
highlights uh a situation uh that
allegedly shows some human rights
violations inside China please play
Mr Chu this was a video that was posted
on Tick Tock by Inez Cantor Freedom are
you familiar with this basketball player
I'm not familiar with the specifics of
this but I can tell you that are you
familiar with the player in this Canter
Freedom Congressman I have no specific
I'm not okay
you have you just have to open Tick Tock
and just search for this kind of content
it really exists I've read the
moderation policy let me just quote what
uh you've talked about content
moderation Tick Tock has a moderation
policy yes
we do have Community guidelines one of
the uh one of the guidelines says
material that in the sole Judgment of
tick tock is objectionable
is this an example Banning in his Cantor
freedom is that an example of
objectionable material inside
the Chinese Communist party in mainland
China we do not we do not take down
content simply because it's critical it
was banned not one week after this video
we do not um we do not do that and if
you need if you need a note go ahead the
note says he's not bad his account was
taken off one week after we can check on
the specifics we can check yeah so uh
let's get to some other questions
um thank you for the slide uh
your privacy uh policy states that you
collect a great array of data keystroke
patterns app file names and types
sometimes approximate location GPS
location
um are keystroke patterns and rhythms
part of tick tock Gathering uh the data
that is gathered big shock
if you're talking a congressman
specifically about keystrokes you know
keystrokes we do not we do not engage in
keystroke logging to monitor what the
users say is to identify Bots okay for
security purposes and this is a standard
industry practice you gather a lot of
data safe to say we don't get them we
don't believe together more than any
other social media Tick Tock gathers a
lot of data because your value
proposition as you set in my office and
told me was to connect people to each
other around the world you told me this
in my office so you gather data on what
they like and what they don't like and
then you show them things that they
don't know they like but eventually they
may
you told me this I I think that's uh I
don't think that's what I said what I
said is that we connect people together
yes
interesting those and that doesn't mean
that we collect more are you aware of
any instances of tick tock Distributing
content from Chinese State media
I'm sorry are you aware of any instances
of tick tock Distributing content from
Chinese State media on the platform we
will label them clearly to for our users
to understand that do you disagree with
FBI director Ray and NSA director
nakasone when they said that the CCP
could have the capability to manipulate
data and send it to the United States do
you disagree with their statement their
statement says could so do you disagree
with that no I don't disagree with that
okay so it is possible that the CCP
under the auspices of bite dance which
is your parent company which you get
paid from has the ability to manipulate
content that is being shared with 130
million Americans yes Congressman I
watch this one make sure I'm
understanding all these questions I
don't disagree with them that that data
risk in general that's what I meant
there's a big data risk on us
specifically are there Engineers located
inside mainland China that work on tick
tock not deutsion but Tick Tock yeah we
are not the only company that has that
are there Engineers inside mainland
China currently working on the algorithm
for tick tock Congressman like I said
there are other companies that as I told
you in your office the other way I'm
going to reclaim my time uh please
rename your project Texas is not the
appropriate name we stand for freedom
and transparency and we don't want your
project I yield back
gentleman yields back gentlelady from
Tennessee is recognized for five minutes
Mrs Hershberger thank you madam chair
and thank you Mr Chu for being here
today
um both president Trump and now
President Biden have back forcing
Tick-Tock to sail to an American company
however the Chinese Communist party has
put export controls on algorithms bike
dance-ons that power Tick Tock and of
course this is created a gauntlet of
regulatory hurdles in China in the U.S
that prevented the sale of tick tock
now as a longtime business owner I want
to tell you Mr Chu that waiting until
your hands are forced uh will only drop
down the price of your app and right now
both your hands are tied
and you're going to have to make a
decision decision about whether you
choose freedom from the CCP or you
continue to be an agent of the CCP and I
I'll tell you why I say it that way as a
former member of Homeland Security I
point blank asks FBI director Ray is
Tick Tock a national security threat and
without hesitation sir he looked at me
and said yes congresswoman it is
now how much data is bite dance
collecting through Tick Tock that's
worth continuing to fight this
regulatory Gauntlet you know why not
take the money and run like any other
company would do
congresswoman we built project Texas in
order to safeguard and we listened to
the concerns that have been raised and
we're building something that's
unprecedented that no other company is
offering to protect U.S user interests
and we believe it is rigorous and robust
and you know we're even offering
third-party transparency and monitors to
come in to verify this frankly I haven't
heard any good reason why this doesn't
work I've heard I've heard a lot of
I've heard a lot of rhetoric around this
but I haven't heard a good reason why it
doesn't work well look forward to these
conversations by the way absolutely well
let me let me go down this road when
Tick Tock was unveiled to the public its
business model was solely based on
generating revenue from advertising of
course spot dance operated a separate
app called Dorian for the Chinese
Marketplace Tick Tock is embarking on
becoming a so-called super app
in other words it's a One-Stop shop with
everything you do as representative
Fulcher said it's reported that tick
tock's algorithms are so powerful that
owner bite dance has begun to license it
to other companies
tick tock's recommendation engine drives
usage on the platform and this leads to
Promises of quick exposure and fame that
leads to P it leads to even more people
joining and when you sign up Tick Tock
starts collecting data about you your
location your gender your age your
facial data the user never gets to the
end of the content and that's by Design
and obviously that makes you a lot of
money
now I know that the Chinese Communist
party is preventing by dance from
selling Tick Tock due to export
restrictions on the technology and this
causes me to question
how are you going to power tick tock
with your Oracle servers located in the
U.S with that Texas Project
with bot dance technology if it can't
leave China how's that going to happen
that I just want you to explain how it's
going to happen
um Congressman the way that we designed
this is so that any piece of software
software that is impactful to the code
that enters you know uh the ticket
that's some technical details around
this will be reviewed by a third-party
um or a few third-party monitors just to
make sure that we're all comfortable
with the code I want to say this again I
don't know of any other other company in
my industry who is offering this level
of transparency
well why are there two different
versions of apps one in China and one in
the United States
it's just a different business
hmm
well I think we all know the reason that
the Chinese get a different version
because bat dance puts China first in
America last and you know Tick Tock has
with everything we've heard today sir
when you see 13 year olds 16 year olds
you see the degradation that's happening
to our youth and our society you know
it's deceptive
in this destructive comment in its
comments and the worst thing is that
it's deliberate sir
and that's not acceptable
and with that chairwoman I yield back
gentlelady yields back gentlelady from
Iowa
Miss Miller makes recognized for five
minutes thank you madam chair and uh
just like to thank our witness Mr Chu
having been in uh in the hot seat so to
speak uh before when I was in state
senate I know how challenging this can
be and thank you for your demeanor
throughout all of this but certainly as
you can see in a bipartisan way we have
concerns and those concerns are valid
um and this is a yes or no question does
tick tock track users individual
keystrokes
only for security purposes for like for
example like detecting Bots but we don't
monitor what users say so the only
purpose that you would monitor
keystrokes is for security purposes I
can get back to you on more specifics
but this is not unlike what many other
companies in the industry does so the
keystroke monitoring does not go beyond
what common industry practice in
comparison to platforms like Facebook or
Instagram use yes yes I believe so okay
um and does tick tock keep records of
users credit cards and passwords
I'm not aware of that you don't need
that to log in of course I can get back
to you on specifics if you make a
transaction on an e-commerce platform
but regardless all that us data will be
stored within the project Texas firewall
um you know within the Oracle Cloud
infrastructure and overseen by American
person so you would store credit card
and password information
uh I need to check on the specifics we
are launching a pilot e-commerce plan
and we're making sure that that data is
very secure within the Oracle Cloud
infrastructure and I think you've made a
point of saying that uh your platform is
not different than other platforms on
social media and therefore are no more
responsible than Facebook or Instagram
or or Twitter or in the other social
media platforms the concern however
comes with where the technology is
generated and whom it is owned by and in
the case of other companies it is
generated in the US under U.S guidelines
under U.S privacy laws with with certain
parameters versus generated through a
parent company bite bands which as we
know is
um
is susceptible to the laws of the
Chinese Communist party which has access
to all of that data and information
um and I understand that Tick Tock has
just reinstated Enos cantor's account
um uh recently
so our concern and the question I have
for you is why would China or the
Chinese Communist Party be opposed to a
forced sell of tick tock
I cannot speak on behalf of the Chinese
government I can say that we design
project taxes to take it Forward here in
the United States and again I believe it
offers unprecedented protection for U.S
user data yeah I think the problem is
when there is a lack of transparency
then that leads people to believe that
there's something more nefarious and
that there is in fact data that is is
captured is stored and poses a risk not
only to children in the United States
but also poses a risk National Security
with that I yield the rest of my time uh
to my colleague Jay overnulty
I thank the gentlelady from Iowa for
yielding Mr Chu I'd like to continue our
discussion about project Texas and the
technical details about what you're
proposing to do so uh
you are migrating All Storage of U.S
user data to the Oracle Cloud
infrastructure and you think that that
will be done by the end of the year was
that right
um again I can get back to you on the
technical
um the technical parts of it the
migration today by default all U.S new
US data is stored so I'm just using what
you said in your testimony in your
opening here it is stored there by
default what I said in my testimony is
I'm deleting Legacy data this is
Virginia and Singapore that's the
difference who when this migration is
complete who will have access to that
data right now A team called Tick Tock
us data security led by American
Personnel you have access to that we
have began this uh operations already
okay but the app itself has access to
the data correct
um only through them you know any
employees that have the data I don't
know what I mean is like if I use lose
my iPhone and I reinstall the app and I
put in my username and password my app
will reconnect to the Mothership and
download some of that data my settings
that's not the way it works no that's
not the way it works it will go through
the Oracle Cloud infrastructure and that
team that looks after this yes I realize
that so let me ask you this what would
prevent then someone with detailed
technical knowledge of the way the app
is constructed from creating an almost
identical version of the app that could
also access that data
they are that's what we are giving you
third-party um monitors and transparency
but they're monitoring the source code
for your app I mean by dance these
Engineers have been working on this app
for years what would prevent them from
making an app they could also access
that data Congressman I think we're
going into the area where you know what
if there's a hacker what if there is
this you know this is a common industry
problem as you know well I mean it's
just I see my times expired it
illustrates the point okay I'm just
skeptical that you're technical as time
has expired General lady's time has
expired Mr Chu I recognize that we have
run over
um I appreciate your time we have just a
few members left and would appreciate
the chance for them to get to answer or
ask their five minutes worth of
questions gentlemen from Virginia Mr
Griffiths is recognized for five minutes
thank you very much Madam chair
Mr Chu
you share legal counsel lawyers with
bite dance yes or no
yes we do and you testified that you
prepared extensively with your legal
team for this hearing yes or no
uh with my team in DC including
including some of your legal counsel yes
yeah and did they tell you about the
report uh to the Australian Senate of
March 14th that I referenced earlier did
they tell you that that report was out
there yes or no
I cannot recall how I found out about
the report did you know about the report
yeah and did they tell you to favorably
cite the citizens lab and your written
testimony today yes or no
Congressman I need to get back to you
they helped you with the prepare
preparation of your written statement
though didn't they a team prepares yes
yes and did they tell you that the
director of Citizen lab says he has
called out your company
for misrepresenting their report
repeatedly and and did so as ladies
yesterday
did they tell you about that yes or no
Congressman the citizen lab is saying
they cannot prove a negative which is
what I've been trying to do for the last
four hours all right
but you cited it favorably as saying
that it did positive things for you that
being said
let me ask you this you keep talking
about transparency
which I haven't been transparent with us
here today
you were asked earlier by Mr Hudson if
you own stock in bite dance you said you
didn't want to reveal that well we're
trying to figure out what the ties are
between bike dance and Tick Tock I'm not
going to ask you how many shares you own
but do you own shares in bite dancer
yes I do all right there you go how
about in tick tock
right now all employees own shares for
sure I expected that I just don't
understand why you didn't tell Mr Hudson
that and we're transparent earlier
instead you made us drag it out of you
all right now let's talk about the kids
you told uh several of our folks that
there was a 60-minute deadline you also
told us that if you were under the age
of 18 you couldn't access the live
section
uh the live option so I texted my 17
year old and my 15 year old and I
basically got scoffs back scoffs when I
said are you all limited to 60 Minutes
my older son said well there is a notice
I get from time to time that says I
shouldn't be on more than 60 minutes but
I'd never kicked me off and my younger
son said oh I'm on as long as I want to
be so I'm just informing you whoever
told you particularly if it was your
legal team
that that's not accurate that they're on
for more than 60 minutes and they can
access the lab section I believe it was
Mr Carter that she said they couldn't
under 18 access the live you know being
on live section
he's done it so whatever it is you think
you're doing it ain't getting done
now let's talk about the law for a
minute
okay
you shared legal team
but you keep talking about how you got a
firewall between you and bite dance
you can't have an effective firewall
under the United States
interpretation of such
if you're sharing legal counsel because
anything that you say to your legal
counsel they can share
internally if you've got the same
lawyers now maybe you have two different
teams of lawyers in the law firm but
that's not what you said to us today you
said you share lawyers there is no
firewall legally I'm just telling you so
if you want to clean it up and be
transparent you need to do something
about that wouldn't you agree yes or no
but you need to do something about that
Congressman
you'll look into it you've been looking
into it all the time all right you told
Dr Burgess when asked uh if your
employees if if if your employees who
were members of the Chinese Communist
Party had access to Tick-Tock data from
the U.S you said you didn't know who was
a member of the Communist party but then
Congressman to Congressman Wahlberg you
said that the CEO of tick tock was not a
member of the Communist the Chinese
Communist party and the congressman
Kelly you said the founder of tick tock
was not a member of the Communist
Chinese party
sir either you know who is and isn't a
member of the Chinese Communist party or
you don't which one is it I submit that
you know and you just aren't giving us
the straight story clearly you know but
you denied that too Dr Burgess I can ask
one or two people but we have no policy
to ask all the employees
I can ask one or two people but like you
know who are in but it's reasonable to
assume that with a significant number of
members of the of the country of China
being members of the Chinese Communist
Party logic would tell us you're a
logical man I assume logic would tell us
that there are a fair number of your
employees who are members of the Chinese
Communist party at least a dozen or so
who have access to this data isn't that
so
again like I said I can ask one or two
people right we don't have a policy
that's everything I said earlier you're
living in some kind of a cloud world
because either you know or you don't
know I yield back thank you man
gentleman from South Carolina chair
recognizes for five minutes Mr Duncan
thank you madam chair I think what's
been revealed today there's not a degree
of separation between uh bite dance and
Tick Tock I'd like to enter in the
record Heritage Foundation document uh
Tick Tock generation a CCP official in
every pocket without objections ordered
and I like the old the balance of my
time to Kelly Armstrong from North
Dakota
thank you madam chair Mr chuda Tick Tock
privacy policy details extensive data
collection on users one line states that
we may collect information about you
from other publicly available sources
what publicly available data is Tick
Tock collecting and adding to the
profiles of users
it will be publicly available but I can
get back to you on specifics
okay what is the purpose of obtaining
even more data on your users beyond the
data collected from the platform
we collect
um data we want to give our users by the
way a lot of transparency on what data
we collect we give them choices on the
controls of their own privacy settings
and it really is to serve them a better
experience this is the reason why so
many people left the app it's a great
experience
so how does so how does the
non-tick-tock related data service
provider relate to the service provided
I I need to check the specifics and
understand the question and get back to
you okay do you think the average Tick
Tock user knows that you are and
understands that tick tock's data
collection extends to information
outside the use of the app
we do give
transparent information on this and like
I said we I we don't I don't believe we
collect more information than most other
social media platforms out there well
and the reason I asked this because I'm
going to go back into the corporate
structure you you describe that Tick
Tock is a subsidiary of by dance uh Mr
Griffith just said that you guys share
the same lawyers you have stated that
your direct report is the CEO of bite
dance but you've also stated that at
certain levels Tick Tock operates
without direct daily control from bite
dance you have used content moderation
as an example for that tick tock's
privacy policy states that use states
that you may share user data within your
corporate group does that corporate
group include bite Downs
um if you are talking about that one
entity that has the share the for the
for Chinese media licensing purposes I
think it's called Beijing throwing
Services if you talk about that entity
if the government share the answer is
you know we have cut off you know excess
of U.S data sets to that so so employees
of The Entity
but your user privacy
white dance is part of your card worker
by this is the is the is the top company
so yeah with you're talking about the
other entities within the group
so you just testified that you
firewalled this does that statement so
you're saying the tick tocks Executives
you that operate independently of bite
dads but does that statement not hold
for sharing of access to data
well I was talking about that one entity
that has um that many of you have very
some concerns you know that's that's the
entity that I'm talking about the entity
with the the Chinese government's um
investment that has that is for the
purpose of Chinese um internet licensing
for the Chinese business now let me ask
it a different way what other entities
have access to Tick-Tock user data well
after project Texas we're going to move
it so that only
um uh Tick Tock user data security has X
has controlled the access of that data
okay so and we could bring you back
either in after project Texas is done
but right now what other entities have
access to tick tock's user data today
only by requirement is really only by
requirement uh certain employees may use
may need the require some excess of data
to help build the product but for us you
know we have moved it for project Texas
and by the end of this year it will be
firewall the way but if this is your
privacy policy today like I I understand
what you're telling us what's
potentially going to happen happen in
the future I have concerns again about
cypheus and government involvement
private organization all of that I'm
just saying this is your user agreement
today so your user agreement says that
you share access with your corporate
group you're telling me what's going to
happen
whenever project Texas gets done I'm
asking you today who has access to tick
tock's user data you know user agreement
Congressman you know privacy policy we
have we also added a link so that our
users in the US can be informed about
project Texas the link is there so the
link is there to private but
I understand what you're trying to do
moving forward I have my own concerns
about that but we're sitting here today
in a hearing and your privacy your
privacy policy is different than your
testimony your privacy policy
specifically says that you can share
user data within your corporate group so
you're saying even though your your
privacy policy says that you're not
doing it like I said I don't think
there's any contradiction here like I
said project Texas when it's done we
file all of that data we still have some
Legacy data in Virginia and Singapore
that we started deleting and will be
done by the end of this year so at the
end of this year then you won't share it
does that mean you're sharing it today
I don't believe so but there is
something why haven't you changed your
privacy policy why haven't you why
haven't you updated it we did update it
and we gave our users more information
on Project Texas we did update it
foreign
gentlemen yields back gentleman from
Texas which I recognizes for five
minutes Mr Crenshaw
thank you madam chair uh thank you Mr
Chu for uh bringing Republicans and
Democrats together I appreciate that I
want to get right to the critical point
of concern so Tick Tock is able to
collect massive amounts of personal data
we all know that that means it could if
it desired to use this data to influence
narratives and Trends create
misinformation campaigns encourage
self-destructive Behavior purposefully
allow drug cartels to communicate freely
and organize human and drug trafficking
and to be fair all social media
companies could do that here's the
difference it is only Tick Tock that is
controlled by the Chinese Communist
party all these other social media
companies are not Mr Chu do you agree
that Tick Tock is controlled by the CCP
no okay I thought you'd say that I
disagree as you thought I might say
um here's why I disagree your parent
company is bite dance right
that's correct it is correct so many of
the workers who work at bite dance
they're Communist party members right
I I wouldn't know well it's well I think
for example the chief editor at bite
dance Zhang Vu ping is the Communist
Party secretary correct
he works on the Chinese business not on
tick tock right he works for bite dance
the parents Works under Chinese business
right the parent company of tick tock
the Chinese business is called toyin
yeah but it's all associated with bite
dance right
um so bike dance owns the number of
businesses right they are you all report
to bite dance everybody's part of bite
dance okay and do you know of any other
employees that work for bite dance that
are part of the Chinese Communist Party
like I said you know they are by dance
has owns Chinese businesses and they
operate in China you don't know how many
but you acknowledge many must be
card-carrying members of the CCP right
in the Chinese business yes yeah I mean
the CCP holds a what's called a golden
share invite dance that allows the CCP
to control one board seat invite dance
that's public that's not correct it's
been publicly reported they admitted to
it is you can on our website we've
updated it so we have can give people
more transparent information on this
they have us share in a subsidiary that
is only for the Chinese business it has
nothing to do with Tick Tock and it's
for the purposes of content Licensing in
China so there's not an internal CCP
committee which is a regular thing that
happens in China they have a CCP
committee internally inside the company
I run Tick Tock I I cannot
representative
no Arrangement and bite dance
so again here's the main point of
concern China's 2017 National
Intelligence law states very clearly
that quote any organization or citizen
shall support assist and cooperate with
State intelligence work in accordance
with the law and maintain the secrecy of
all knowledge of State intelligence work
in other words bite dance and also your
Tick Tock employees that live in China
they must cooperate with Chinese
intelligence whenever they are called
upon and if they are called upon they're
bound to secrecy that would include you
so Mr Chu if the CCP tells bite dance to
turn over all data that Tick Tock has
collected inside the U.S even within
project Texas do they have to do so
according to Chinese law Congressman
first I'm Singaporean
um that's fine but there are employees
of yours and bike dances in China we
understand this concern in my opening
statement we said we hear these concerns
we didn't try to avoid them or you know
trivialize them we build something where
we take that data and put it Out Of
Reach this is what we did we put it Out
Of Reach but they own you no we put it
Out Of Reach by by bringing them by
dance owns Tick Tock if bite dances tell
and the CCP owns bite dance because the
CC cccp owns everybody in China so by
law they can make them do whatever they
want and they say that by law you can't
tell anyone about it so they can make
you hand over that data is that correct
data is stored here in American soil by
an American company
leaked audio from 80 internal Tick Tock
meetings shows that U.S user data has
been repeatedly accessed from China when
you said it hasn't been and here's the
other thing following back on my my
colleague's line of questioning in your
own privacy policy it says that you may
even share information within your
so-called corporate group is bypass part
of that corporate group if you're
talking about this the share of the The
Entity with the with the share I like I
shared with uh the previous um this bite
Dance part of the corporate group
by dance as a holding company is part of
the corporate group yes it's part of the
grover group okay so your own privacy
policy says you have to share data with
bite dance and if the CCP says Hey bite
dance you're going to do what we say and
you can't tell anyone about it because
by law according to that 2017 uh
National Intelligence law they have to
do it that's our concern they haven't
done it yet but my point is that you
might have to and that's where our
concerns come from I mean over 300
Tick-Tock employees have worked for
China's state-run propaganda media
that's just from looking at their
LinkedIn profiles
okay so here and my last point is this I
want to say this to all the teenagers
out there and Tick Tock influencers who
think we're just old and out of touch
and don't know what we're talking about
trying to take away your favorite app
you may not care that your data is being
accessed now but it will be one day when
you do care about it and here's the real
problem with data comes power they can
choose what you see and how you see it
they can make you believe things that
are not true they can encourage you to
engage in behavior that will destroy
your life even if it is not happening
yet it could in the future the long-term
goal of the Chinese Communist party is
the demise of the American power and
that starts with our youth at any moment
they could demand that all of tick
tock's data be used to design an AI
algorithm with the sole purpose of
promoting Chinese interests and
destroying our society from within you
want to know why that's Democrat why
that's why Democrats and Republicans
have come together on this that's why we
are so concerned thank you and I yield
back
of course they have 10 business days to
submit questions for the record
and I ask our witness to respond to the
questions promptly
pursuant to committee rules I ask
unanimous consent to enter the documents
from the staff list into the record
without objection so ordered members
should submit their questions by the
close of business on April 6th without
objection the committee is adjourned
foreign
um
[Music]
yeah
characters
foreign
thank you
later
again
foreign
[Music]